the pentagon has ordered a
full stand down of the entire military
in the next 60 days
because they're trying to figure out how
to purge
white nationalism and extremism on the
surface
i think it's a good it sounds like a
good idea right sounds like a good idea
if there are people who are you know
white supremacists white nationalists or
extremists
we don't want them in the military i
mean there are stories about gangs i'm
not going to name some of them but they
infiltrate the military and their
allegiance is not to the united states
so we need to make sure that the people
who are you know in our armed forces
well they're here to serve the people of
this country the problem is
this is stemming from what we saw in
washington dc
where there were national guardsmen who
had like the gadsden flag on their
facebook page and got removed
and some people who were members of the
nra and got removed
and now they're claiming that literally
everybody in the capital is
you know on the six was some kind of
extremist when many of these people were
befuddled or bewild
bewildered walking into open doors open
for them by police
certainly what happened at the capitol
was was really really bad it was
horrifying and the people who stormed
the into the building should be
prosecuted and you know
held accountable but there are a lot of
people who are just down there
and this is part of the purge we've
heard of people who are simply hearing
trump speak who have been investigated
who have been fired from their jobs and
now we're hearing the military is doing
a
legit full stand down this is not some
simple
uh well i'll put it this way i hope
i'm you know the optimistic side of me
says maybe they just really want to
crack down on this extremism
which would be good but the realistic
you know part of me says it sounds more
like they're going to be doing a kind of
loyalty testing
where gadsden flags and the declaration
of independence
and you know the original american flag
these things are signs that you're an
extremist the left refers to people who
have the gadsden flag a sign of the deck
of the american of american independence
and revolution as
a symbol of white supremacy so who do
you think they will be targeting with
someone like this
this is where things start to get a bit
freaky so we'll be talking a lot about
this
we've got some some news about joe biden
and marjorie taylor green
the democrats have just removed her from
all of her committees it's just another
sign
they said they wanted truth and
reconciliation commissions they want a
reality czar
and now we're heading out the direction
now we have an op-ed claiming i think
tom brady
said he shouldn't get away with
supporting trump it is
starting to happen read your history
books we'll
we'll we'll dive right into this we're
joined by the president of the new york
young republicans gavin wax
thank you for having me man yeah you
want to just introduce yourself a little
bit uh gavin wax president of new york
and republicans uh recently reoccupied
wall street so uh
it was a little cold but you know we had
our message gave up real quick yeah we
were we were kind of
we were lame in that regard but you know
it's still what what does your club do
was it new york
uh we're we're basically a support
network for people who are uh to the
right of ruth bader ginsburg in the five
do boroughs we uh you know we we we give
people food
shelter whatever they may need to
survive in uh in liberal land
you were you so before we even started
the show you were mentioning you had
friends
in the in the military yeah mentioning
so national guard yeah they were talking
about this earlier
we'll get into all this uh of course
we're joined by the parking lot dwelling
lucrative the fact that you're still in
new york city is absolutely crazy
i don't know what the hell you're doing
there i left i'm very happy that i left
welcome back beautiful and amazing human
beings my name is looked at ascii of we
are change.org
i'm an independent journalist and if you
want to find out more information about
me
uh sign up on my email list on we are
changing the drawing in the top right
hand corner thanks for watching
look at your shirt disparaging people
who play football uh well
you know yeah technically i guess you
could say that
uh
i should have put someone taking a
selfie uh i think that was more accurate
but i made this shirt like 10 years ago
and i just brought it back on of course
our t-shirt store but luke used to go to
bars during the super bowl and then like
quiz people on like two really easy pop
culture questions
and like a very serious like how many
people did barack obama murder oh my god
it was a drinking game and during the
super bowl i was like if you get these
three
questions right i pay off your bar bill
oh if
you get one of them wrong i have to take
a shot
and i got hammered oh no i got
obliterated but i asked questions like
like
yeah yeah i was like who's the
quarterback who's the coach whatever
whatever football question
third question third question was like
uh what happened in fukushima
or how many how many american citizens
did barack obama drone bomb and
assassinate
how many wars did barack obama get
involved in what's the us national debt
no one knew and i got and i got i was
puking in one video
never once not one guy not one guy ever
i think there was one
yeah a couple of them got it they're
like um well i forgot the exact kind of
question but one guy was just
on it and surprised the crap out of me
and we kept going after questions and i
bought him a whole bunch of drinks and
we had a whole bunch of and then
afterwards he's like ron paul but yeah
yeah
but i remember i remember having such a
crazy time
partying puking getting kicked out of so
many bars because
again people are like what the hell are
you doing why are you filming here i'm
like don't worry it's fine i'm i'm i'm
with
you know the official people here
they're like what official people i'm
not just some official people
and i had so much fun sadly we can't do
that now because of uh
coven yeah i would have done that
because the super bowl is coming up
yeah yeah we also got uh you know ian
he's showing up guys thanks for having
me tim uh
just want to give a shout out to this
kombucha i just brewed kombucha over the
last month
so cool and this is day one this is a
pear clove ginger
ian just turned out really really good
ian's drinking a
homemade potion of some sort drinking it
throughout the show i just don't like
kombucha
but everyone everyone apparently liked
it i guess so yeah so far so good yeah
give these a flavor
but we also got sour patch let's the
buttons i'm in the corner pushing
buttons that is my job and i do it as
well as i can
all right well ladies and gentlemen
before we read this uh shocking news and
then
we've also got some other segments too
we'll talk about ufos i want i want to
just have a little bit more phone stuff
we got we have another really really
crazy story
where this dude on a security camera
murders his neighbors
with a handgun and then an ar of some
sort there's a lot to talk about with
the story because it's shocking
it's in full view of the camera you can
hear people screaming and there's a lot
we i'm not going to play the video you
know
we'll show you some of the story but
we're gonna get in that stuff as well
but before we do make sure you go to
timcast.com
become a member because we have
exclusive bone we have exclusive
episodes and segments
available only to those who are members
you guys who sign up are our shield and
our safety net
is very likely in the future as the
purge continues we will get wrapped up
in it
we have one story coming from the blaze
about it's from the blaze a conservative
outlet
about progressives getting purged from
youtube a lot of progressives are now
getting knocked out
so look we may be a little milk toasted
in the middle here but
i think it's only a matter of time
that's why we say that's why we're
setting up timcast.com we're gonna be
expanding and we need you to become
members because that is the shield
if we get purged we'll at least be able
to still put up episodes on the website
and still provide you with hours of
amazing exclusive content because we got
full episodes we got one
from the second it's a whole hour-long
discussion about religion life after
death and exorcisms and
and stuff like that so you can check
that out don't forget to like subscribe
to the notification bell and let's jump
to that first
story this is from reuters pentagon
stumped by extremism in the ranks orders
stand down in next
60 days they say the us military on
wednesday acknowledged
it was unsure about how to address white
nationalism and
other extremism in its ranks and
announced plans for military-wide
stand-downs
causing regular activity at some point
in the next 60 days to tackle the issue
the decision to hold a stand down was
made by lloyd austin
who made history by becoming the
military's first black defense secretary
after a long career rising in the ranks
of the army in his confirmation hearing
austin underscored the need to rid of
the military of
racists and extremists pentagon
spokesman john kirby said austin ordered
the stand down after a meeting with the
us military branch leaders
who are under pressure to show progress
in combating extremism
after current and former military
service members were found to have
participated in the siege of the u.s
capitol on january 6.
the pentagon has yet to define how it
will deal with extremism or offer data
estimating
how many service members hold white
nationalist ideology
it is also not disclosed how many troops
have been disciplined for extremism
quote we don't know how we're going to
be able to get after this in a
meaningful productive tangible way
and that is why we had this meeting
today and that is why he certainly
ordered this stand down
kirby told reporters it was unclear
whether the announcement was meant to
foreshadow any near-term concrete
actions by joe biden's pentagon
or whether the stand down was more of a
symbolic move meant to demonstrate
austin's acknowledgment
of the problem and continued resolve the
first thing i'll say on this segment
if they really know that there's white
nationalism in the military they gotta
get rid of it
they gotta do everything they can to
find these people and these people in my
opinion
should not be should not be serving look
there's a there's a line between
being an adherent to an extremist
ideology and having
opinions that won't impact your job i
think people are allowed to have those
opinions
so i'm specifically referring to those
who are expressing a desire for some
kind of ideological
outcome and seemingly a willingness to
be more loyal
to that ideology than this country
however
i don't trust these people that's what
worries me we already saw in dc some
dude had a gadsden flag
post on facebook so they got they kicked
him out of dc they kicked him off the
mission
one dude was like posting about the nra
so that was gone
and we know how the left and
establishment democrats define
racism and white nationalism they say
trump is a white nationalist
they say all of trump supporters all of
trump's supporters are racists
it's not true meanwhile kamala harris
literally fundraised for the rioters
that in the george floyd riots
and that resulted in 19 deaths
they literally defend extremists then
they tell you the
other people who oppose it are the
extremists we can see how they're
treating what happened on january 6
certainly a
bad moment but now they're trying to
look at aoc
she came out with this huge fabricated
story she claimed
you know that she was thought she was
going to die when this cop knocked on
her door
now it turns out not only was she not in
the capitol building
but her story took place at 1pm a full
hour and 10 minutes
before anyone breached the capitol
building in the first place
the time she told her story people had
only gotten past the first barricade
so they're lying they are the extremists
and what really worries me is like i
said like i said
if they want to get rid of real
ideological extremists i'm cool with
that
but if what they're really doing is
loyalty testing
and purging the military of anybody who
might support the idea of american
independence and liberty we got
ourselves a very very serious problem
because it extends well beyond the
military
but what we're seeing in dc for instance
permanent barricades barbed wire
they're saying it's going to be
permanent a green zone in dc 5 000
troops
it's an occupation and now they're
getting rid of those disloyal
it sounds like we are headed towards
some truly horrific nightmare
we're living in it man this is a
dystopian dystopian novel yep and this
is also happening on the backdrop of the
fbi
expanding their activities finally being
mobilized and activated like we've never
seen before
on top of elements in the mainstream
media specifically npr
calling for cia counter insurgency
operations and tactics
inside of the united states now when you
look at the history of the cia counter
intelligence insurgency operations what
are they going to do
are they going to start arming
terrorists and bombing weddings in the
united states
i mean are are you kidding me uh and
again we have to understand here this is
happening at at a time where you know a
lot is going on so there's a lot of room
for concerns
rapid yeah it's rapid man looks like all
the opening moves if you just you know
suffered a coup d'etat this is exactly
out of the hab book it's like you know
get loyalty tests you know purge the
military start investigating your own
people it's not what a free society does
this is what a very unfree
unhealthy society does and you know
everything they were accusing trump of
doing i mean it's it's happening right
before our very eyes it's it's
self-projecting it's either gaslighting
to mask it it's it's pretty scary
so you you you were mentioning you knew
people in the national guard were
talking about this yeah i mean i i got
messages today about it before i think
it was really like started to trend it
became a topic and i read it i was like
this is insane i mean they're going to
use this as a cart launch to get rid of
essentially anyone uh
who is just slightly to the right of
maybe ruth bader ginsburg anyone who
doesn't adhere to everything in the
establishment's orthodoxy
is done and they could they they make up
i mean the nra members
a member of a tpusa organization i mean
you could be part of very mainstream
conservative organizations and they will
use that as a way to label you as you
know a white supremacist
look what they did the rnc right so we
had this digital rnc you know
it wasn't a big crowd you had a couple
black politicians and speakers
and the and the democrats on the left
has said they were tokenizing them
and i'm like yo you complain that the
republicans are too white and then when
they
when they bring up people of color you
complain that they're using people of
color it's like there's literally
nothing you can do you can't win you
can't win yeah
it's just they've set it up in such a
way that they are always right they've
covered all the bases
it is very obviously an extremist
authoritarian ideology
some of these progressive youtubers were
defending anti for burning down small
businesses
and then defended 25 000 armed fully
armed
with the authority to kill national
guardsmen in washington dc
so how do you defend the destruction of
the working class the businesses
and then the power of the state unless
you are an authoritarian wing nut
it's all about power they don't care and
then every time the republicans do this
all the time they always try to bring up
the hypocrisy and the double standards
they don't care they're shameless
they just say the biggest lie over and
over again until it becomes truth and
we've seen a lot of people
buy into it you know the sheeple
whatever you want to call them and you
know
they're just regurgitating what they're
told because it eventually it becomes
you know in an orwellian sense the only
truth these stalin
kind of loyalty tests are going to be
interesting because i know a few people
in the military
and after being in the military a lot of
them are disenfranchised with the
military
with the government whether it's the
government lying to them to get
them in there was a recent video my
friend was showing me uh
it was on tick tock and it was a random
national guards member going up to
troops being like hey why'd you enlist
why'd you sign up
and all of them i came and say what they
said family-friendly show here but the
the gist was i'm stupid i don't know
what i'm doing i just wanted a check
and a lot of them don't even get to
check because they get lied to by the
recruiters to get in there
and that's not even talking about the
larger issues of the history of agent
orange depleted uranium
and the us government using its troops
literally like pawns
for psychological chemical weapons
testing and all these other kind of
weird experiments that no one even wants
to talk about so there's a big segment
of the us military
that is disenfranchised and the more
that they're in the system the more
anti-government they become so these
loyalty tests are going to be very
interesting
especially with something like a joe
biden presidency when we're seeing
the representation and the response to
them especially online now of course
this is a perfect representation but if
you look at the white house youtube
channel
uh the like to dislike ratio is crazy
they haven't shut that down yet well so
this is an important comment because you
know
the first reaction for many leftists is
just because right wingers brigade
you know send all their followers to
down dislike something
doesn't prove its general sentiment and
my response to that because so basically
it's like this
why is it that the white house videos
are all thumbs down well what they say
is
you know 4chan or reddit or patreon or
whatever will tell everyone hey go here
and give it a thumbs down
or they'll post the video then everyone
will go and give it a thumbs down if
that's the case if that's what they
believe what they're saying is the left
has no organizational power
to you know online but i think what the
reality is
those who seek out information who are
you know
who learn through critical thought are
more likely to oppose the orthodoxy
left and right is it doesn't mean
anything right now what they're saying
is like you know when they say tim pool
is right when i actually find it kind of
hilarious that i can have so many left
wing policy opinions
and agree you know very much much more
often with someone on the left on
economic or social issues
and then they call that right wing why
the difference is critical thinking and
challenging the establishment what left
and right is becoming is
pro-establishment versus
anti-establishment
and that's why they go after jimmy dore
that's why they banned a bunch of
progressives why they why they why
youtube kicked out graham elwood these
are progressives who challenge the
establishment
so their best you know vector of attack
is you're the other you're evil right
wing is bad
that's that that's what we're gonna you
know that's what we've been seeing the
tribalism you've talked about this right
everyone in their tribes and it just
creates this this dichotomy and this
dynamic that it's like you're fighting
the other and it dehumanizes them but i
think what's interesting about what's
going on with these these loyalty tests
is that the military has traditionally
been one of the last institutions that
i'm not saying it was you know
completely right wing but it was
certainly
center center right and it's the one
institution that they really haven't had
a full
amount of control over and if you really
want to completely take over society
yes you can have the media yes you could
have big tech yes you could have
academia all these other major
institutions but at the end of the day
to really enforce
a lot of their dystopian agenda it needs
to have someone
with a gun and the end of the gun being
pointed at you essentially they don't
have police and they don't have police
and they don't have the military now
they finally have their political power
they have their media power
this is one of the last steps to full
consolidation it's very scary and
they're trying to get the military to
wear high heels
as pointed out when alex jones came off
yeah and we didn't believe him yeah we
were like get out of here yeah
crazy and as this is happening we have
to understand on the backdrop we got
information from the bbc today that came
out in an article highlighting
how the chinese government is trying to
promote education to make men
more masculine in order to prevent the
feminization of young boys
we also have to understand this is on
the backdrop of many prominent
chinese government licked organizations
and institutions
financing a lot of top colleges in the
united states
that make masculinity look bad
so this could be a larger play here this
is obviously speculation but
if you kind of connect the dots here i
think there's an argument to make well
china knows what's happening in the u.s
they know the demoralization they know
the crumbling
of society it's happening and they're
trying to do everything they can to make
sure their own society is actually well
off so
they're acting in their own nation's
best interests our elites are not that's
the difference between their elites and
our elites i mean
they're repugnant for sure but at least
they have their nation's self-interest
to some degree right
mike pompeo said that we've been
infiltrated by china at every single
level
every state every institution is it
possible that this
is a cultural attack against the us
exploiting our weaknesses
free speech is a great thing but it
creates a attack vector
the the right of crazy people to say
crazy things and win once they have
economic power
what better way to take over a country
than have it fight itself
right you know if you were china if you
were another competing country on the
world stage and you wanted to take it
over you know
there's a whole bunch of armed
individuals they have a whole bunch of
guns
there's a whole bunch of sovereign
individuals there that are you know
our anti-government don't like authority
will never like us we got to get rid of
what better way than to do everything
that's being done now sorry i cut you
off no
i was cutting you off but thank you uh
no it's the kgb guy yuri besmanov he
said demoralize them i mean you're not
going to beat them in open combat you're
not going to beat them through an
invasion
you demoralize society you make society
hate itself you make society divided
and then it crumbles beneath it i mean
it's better than economics and it's the
only way because
geographically america is in a very
unique position you look at china it's
at a very
geopolitically weak position india this
is why they're fighting off
you know to make sure that they have the
island of taiwan this is why they're
building the the
islands in the south china sea this is
why they're fighting the indians in that
territory
because where they are on the world
stage is very bad for any kind of fight
that would happen right the united
states is in an amazing place
very safe and the only way to really
take it down is to of course make it
fight itself
i think it's not it's not even just
where the us is it's also the territory
of the us i mean think about if they
tried to come from the western
coast we got the rockies not something
easy they could get equipment over
so there's no real ground invasion
that's never gonna happen plus we're
armed to the teeth
right how many guns are in this country
what do we have 4.3 million background
checks
in january a good thing beautiful that
is a lot of guns
we don't know all those background
checks don't always result in a gun
but a lot of people in this country have
guns so there's that that mean court i
don't know if it's real about a gun
behind every blade of grass
so it's got to be psychological warfare
yeah they'll spend like decades
with this demoralization according to
yuri besmanov he said they'll do two
three decades
of just demoralization he said that we
were done he said i think what was it
the 80s 90s he was like you guys are
already there
yeah because the universities the
university g edward griffin interviewed
him
and he's still you know writing books
he's the guy who wrote the creature from
jekyll island he would be a great uh
guest to have on
but according to brookings there's more
guns than people in the united states
beautiful of course so uh that's what
they're scared
we're talking about more than like
foreign
we we were joking about not really
joking we were talking and lamenting
about seth rogen being a really mean
person right so
it's kind of silly and a lot of people
probably think it's meaningless but i
think this is one of the most important
aspects of how we will be crushed by
china
believe it or not i'm going to say in
the upcoming conflict the ongoing
conflict with china
the us will be defeated and a good
example of why is seth rogen being a bad
person
seth rogen responded to a guy from
quillette named jonathan k just saying
you are stupid
it was a meaningless post there was no
reason to say it it was just an
awful thing to be and what this shows is
people in this country from the smallest
angry
twitterer to the wealthiest most famous
celebrity they're just
be they've become completely demoralized
there's literally no reason for this
i saw something that really broke my
heart earlier i don't know if you guys
saw the story carrie elwiss
insulted ted cruz saying everyone from
the cast and crew you know just
finds you it despises you or whatever
and you're a humongous rouse or
something like that
and then ted cruz responded with does
this mean you want your picture back
and it was a picture of carrie elwis as
the dread pirate roberts and princess
bride and it was signed to ted cruz by
carrie ellis
that means at some point carrie met with
ted cruz
and probably shook his hand and said
here's a picture of me or send it to him
and sign it for him that's a sign of
respect
because they knew ted cruz loves the
princess brides a very famous movie from
the 80s
and now we're at a point where the
demoralization is so
within us that carrie elwes who once
gave this gift ted cruz
is smack talking him on twitter for no
reason
why is everyone so awful you know what
it could just be that we are victims of
our own success and we have created
these big social
platforms that have manipulated us and
it's and it's entirely possible that
like yuri basmanov said
the this is the weakness of the united
states and we have been demoralized and
this is
regardless of whether china wants it to
happen i think when you talk about mike
pompeo saying we've been infiltrated at
every level
then it's it stands to reason that this
is playing exactly into their hands
it's not that everyone's awful it's like
if we're all chilling in a room and one
person comes in and starts screaming
it ruins the room for everyone you know
that's a virus
and that's similar to twitter you get
these loud idiots that are
a vocal minority but i think it's not
just so outside and
it's not it's not it's not my no it's
not the minority it's everywhere it's
every single person not me
fair no i know i know i know it's the
it's what i would say is it's most
people who are active on twitter
most people like conservatives do it all
the time like luke was making fun of aoc
all day
wow it was a lot of memes it was a lot
of videos and i thought they were
hilarious and i think i know during this
situation i think it's important to
laugh
you need to laugh but the problem is
it's always at the expense of other
people
i called aoc a liar who was manipulating
us and she fabricated her story and i
proved on the timeline
but crowder called her a horse face yeah
i don't go far
right so the problem is criticism is
okay when people are doing things that
are bad and aoc is one of the biggest
contributors to demoralization in this
country
but i don't like the the the like we
have to get away
from being vicious and nasty because
that's what's weakening us
look luke pointed out the story from the
bbc china promotes education drive to
make boys
more manly it is the opposite of what we
are doing here in this country like you
mentioned
we need to teach people like stoicism
pragmatism
to be strong and resilient and calm and
controlled in their emotions we have to
relearn the classics we have to relearn
everything that they knew
in ancient times i mean i feel like
modernity has shown us that
he's given this arrogance that we're you
know it's we're at the best point in our
our development as a society as as
humans
when in reality we've regressed in many
areas yes our technology's better yes
some economic things are better
but in a lot of ways in an individual
level i mean in terms of people being
more independent people being
more free thinking we've regressed so
far so far well even just
beyond that specifically talking about
what's happening in men
in china they're dealing with a huge
population crisis that is coming to a
head
that's going to lead to a lot of
problems inside of china
and and when you look at it
statistically testosterone
and sperm levels are down dramatically
and they're going down through
through throughout the last few years in
a way that's absolutely shocking and
should
scare the crap out of everyone uh
particularly
in the west where of course we are
seeing essentially just the the
uh what people are calling a chemical
warfare against men well if you want to
control a society you don't want a
society full of uh
angry men who are well read who know
their history who know what's going on
you want a society full of uh you know
soy boys essentially who
don't know their history who are just
well adamantly stand up for themselves
they can't stand up for themselves
they don't know their past they don't
know their future they're just kind of
living in the moment in this consumerist
society
those are the easiest people to control
don't have a family no family no roots
nothing they're just driftless
in in mind and body and you know and
those are perfect individuals for you
know big multinational corporations to
profit off of because they're always
going to have a customer exactly when
someone would have a family when someone
would have you know
you know values and important things to
work towards and do their transcendence
they're not going to be
looking for happiness inside of a happy
meal or inside of
the next product that they buy their
happiness
they're going to feel content which is
going to make them a worse off consumer
so
on many levels this works uh for the
benefit of of course the billionaire
class
geopolitically for for other countries
and of course not to the benefit of you
me or anyone else listening right
do you guys remember the try guys oh my
god where they had those
the below like two standard deviations
of t levels so i i tried finding uh so
for those aren't familiar and now that
we you know we've talked about china and
masculinity
china wants to make their men more
masculine and in the us you know like
luke mentioned testosterone levels are
down sperm counts are down reproduction
is going down
and there's there's a group of guys that
were on buzzfeed i don't i don't think
they're there anymore they were called
the try guys
so they decided to do a segment where
they test their tested their
testosterone levels
and their testosterone levels were that
of
seniors senior citizens that are like
pre-pubescent boys or something
or girls or girls yeah i don't know of
women yeah
it was really bad so so i actually have
this uh this article i couldn't find a
good article talking about the results
because
the original video they did just said
hey look we got our testosterone tested
how fun but then a lot of people
realized
whoa these guys have dangerously low
levels of testosterone
so i found a website called the four
second hard on and they say buzzfeed's
tri guys have dangerously low
testosterone that's from december of
2017.
they say the buzzfeed tri guys are a
stereotypical group of beta male
millennials
that try various weird things and record
their feminine reactions on youtube i
don't think
it is the best article i could find so
forgive the snark
if you have the misfortune to watch any
of their content you probably notice
something's a little off you'd be
correct
in one of their antics they tried to
find out who was the most attractive man
one of the things they did was have
blood work done to measure their
testosterone levels
the daily wire reports actually you know
what can i just pull the daily wire
because they'd be a little bit less
bombastic
so no that's not even there anymore all
right so they say quote
the normal t-score for an adult male
ranges from 270 to one
1070 ng dl would you know what that
means leah
no ng slash deal sorry with men aged
from 25 to 34 averaging at
617 ng dl so that's nanograms per
deciliter
whatever that means just a measurement
all right not one buzzfeed beta male
met the 617 average rather all of the
men tested below the level of a typical
85 year old male moreover
three of the four men tested below the
average range the average range
and the male with the highest
testosterone level eugene still had a
relatively low t
score with 363 ng slash dl
why is it like i don't know i don't know
food
plastics no exercise maybe micro
plastics
i was reading about how we have this
bottle this bottled water right
no offense to this bottled water company
yeah but there's what is it called like
micropressed the plastics that mimic
estrogen
yeah inside of them especially if the
bottle is uh
you know exposed to heat and cold and
expansion uh but it's also
alcohol it's also mint it's also you
know
breads many people don't even know this
mint lowers your testosterone
i've looked into this trust me i got my
testosterone tested a whole bunch of
times
were you good yes i was very happy with
my levels i was like all right i did it
the slavic level starts higher as yeah i
think so i wasn't born in the united
states
and i think that also helps a lot too uh
you know i was exposed to a whole
different kind of way of life your
radiation levels are way higher though
yes because of uh chernobyl which i was
actually born
very close to and afterwards and i was
still in my mom's belly so that could
understand my fraudulent slips sometimes
uh
but freud yes you know what i said
freudian
you almost got i'm messing with you i'm
messing with you 3d chess here okay
all right uh what you guys caught me off
guard but also most importantly um
so yes uh mint alcohol some people even
point to bread a lot of fake food lack
of exercise lack of sleep a lot of
stress microplastics
and and those are only some of the
theories out there of what's leading to
this there's other beliefs that there's
even more
but again testosterone sperm levels
reproduction levels
absolutely low very dangerous no one
wants to talk about it they should be
talking about it because
testosterone is not only key to men's
physical
health not only to your bones not only
towards your muscles not only to your
towards your physical structure but also
your mental health so
if you're lacking in testosterone this
could explain why so many people are
out of it loopy and crazy and we're
having a mental health crisis
because they don't have the proper
amount of hormones and you need to
manipulate so
exactly i want to stress i mean no
disrespect to the try guys
i'm just you know i i i mean sincerely
i'm pointing out this
is a serious issue so in one of the
image they show we can see
that the the for the lowest guy ned had
had a t-score of 212
and for someone who's 85 to 100 it
should be 376.
there is seriously something wrong i
mean this is a bigger public health
crisis than coronavirus but no one's
talking about it
but if if your t levels are below them
an 85 year old men shouldn't you go for
like a screening of some sort to figure
out what's wrong could that be something
more serious
has anyone ever i mean if you go into
like a regular checkup this is not a
normal procedure it should be
like when they check everything i have
to make sure like i get it right and i
have to fight them sometimes
i'm like because i get a blood test
every six months just to check out my
levels
just to see how i'm doing on my you know
minerals and nutrients and all this
other vitamin stuff
making sure my body's running you know
well and they're like oh you don't need
it you're fine you're in your throat i'm
like no no
no no make it make sure you put it on
there because they just refuse to do it
many times so let me
let me show you this uh i pulled up i
just did a quick google search it's from
2007.
generational decline in testosterone
levels observed trend does not seem to
be attributable to health and lifestyle
changes
they say during the past two decades
testosterone levels in american men have
rapidly declined
this information comes from a long-term
prospective study that evaluated changes
in serum testosterone on a
population-wide basis
the study was published in the journal
of clinical and endocrinology
and metabolism they say the interesting
thing we discovered was
that on average when we measured the
testosterone in the blood of a 60 year
old in 1989
it was higher than that in a different
60 year old measured in 1995
said thomas travison phd of the new
england research institute's watertown
massachusetts
we observe the same phenomenon over a
wide range of ages
they say although testosterone loss is
common as men age
it is often associated with diabetes
abdominal obesity
sexual dysfunction depression and other
adverse conditions
the massachusetts male aging study was
composed of randomly selected men ages
45 to 79
living in the boston area i'm not going
to go through all of the you know
you know full details on how the study
was done just that for the past couple
of decades now
or i should say decade and a half-ish
we've been seeing that there's some kind
of decline in testosterone among men
not related to lifestyle or what do they
say health and lifestyle
for diet personally i just did i just
reminded myself because i remember doing
a lot of research about this a few years
ago
but it's also a lot of processed food
flax seeds
vegetable oils along with what i
mentioned before mint alcohol
that do have a very negative effect on
you and remember they surprisingly weird
they said you weren't supposed to eat
eggs for a while eggs was bad red meat
and all those things they they move them
back up the the pyramid
or the food pyramid because they have
healthy fats healthy fats but also you
guys remember
they used to talk about ancient rome
with the lead and the aqueducts and
stuff and that had an impact on people's
health and i think if i remember
correctly the lead
in their uh impacted testosterone
invasion rome i mean there may be
something going on now that we don't
know about the plastics whatever
maybe in a thousand years we'll know
high fructose corn syrup maybe not
really maybe
at the mainstream food supply in 1989
they're about it's banned in europe is
that true
you know the interesting europe's just
as bad so the interesting thing about
the study though is they mentioned
1989 to 1995 it's not like these are
different generations it's not like
there's a genetic genetics being passed
down or whatever
89 to 95 yeah yeah that's when high
fructose corn syrup hit the market
well so if you have a 60 year old in
1989 and that's that means you have
the the 60 year old at the time was 54
so maybe there's something about
you know you go back to the 50s and
we've been introducing more and more of
something that's caused some
kind of well also the sugar industry put
out a bunch of
pr and and bribed a bunch of doctors to
say that fats are
really bad for you and if you walk
around the supermarket you see
everything non-fat
low fat and those are the worst for you
and there's been a lot of misinformation
surrounding fat
good fat bad fat that of course was just
totally wiped out with this larger pr
campaign that was launched by the sugar
industry because
if you look at foods now everything has
a ton of
crazy processed sugar in there but very
few things actually have natural fat and
natural fat is also
very key important not only for your
physical health but also your mental
health this could be it i mean it could
be a bunch of guys who are not getting
any fat in their diet maybe they're
vegan
so they're you know no disrespect to
vegans but probably getting a lot more
fiber a lot more sugar and a lot less
protein and fat
i mean have you ever seen a healthy
vegan i mean they generally don't look
healthy i mean that's an anecdote but i
mean
we've never seen them look great the
truths are pretty healthy but they
supplement
hard adam and nisha they live here in
the house and they know all the secrets
but
that's the thing you have to have like
yeah you have to go the extra mile
time too vitamin b deficiency is huge i
would imagine iron deficiency iron
deficiency
fat because uh i'm not i'm not a
nutritionist or anything but my
understanding is that
there's like heme iron and non-heme iron
you go fact check me on this one
but i was reading that when you get iron
from say a steak your body absorbs it
right away but from vegetables it
doesn't unless you have vitamin c
so you eat meat you're getting your iron
you're getting your vitamin b
you're not getting that if you're if
you're on a vegan diet yeah so many
people are deficient in micronutrients
and vitamins
and a lot of the food especially i
believe there was a study done comparing
the actual nutritional levels of food
and vegetables and fruits just a couple
years ago to now and that's also
declining
and that could be a response because of
factory farming
you want to say something yeah i do
actually have a lot i want to say about
this stuff because i
love this kind of stuff so ian was
talking about how he thinks that the
introduction of stuff like high fructose
corn syrup is
might be causing part of the problem i
think that i would probably accredit the
whole
larger problem to the problem of obesity
which i would then attribute to the
problem with our microbiome which is
something that no
almost nobody ever talks about but this
is everything we do these guys
i've taken probiotics pre prebiotics the
last two three months i have felt
so much it's it's crazy i took it on a
whole nother level i started getting
customized probiotics and started
working
and even doing affiliate sales because i
was so happy with the results that i
found
where you literally have to doodoo in a
cup and send it to a laboratory
and they sent you and then they test out
your gut my gut you know
they tell you things about you that you
didn't even know based off your
your gut is a lot i'm wondering if maybe
there's something related to
the um the higher crop yield that we've
seen
from crops due to you know you have
people like norman borlaug who's his
famous scientist who figured out how to
get more wheat
out of a typical you know yield or
whatever to save to save people from
starvation he's a brilliant guy people
consider he's
a great hero and scientist but there's a
concern that there's less and less
nutrients
in the crops we're growing as we grow
more and more and more and make it more
dense but as the carbon dioxide night
i would really need to fact check this
but as the carbon dioxide levels have
increased on planet earth the plants
have been getting bigger but they
haven't been getting more nutritious
it's almost like they're getting
more obese no they're getting more
carbon in them which is just the basic
building blocks of plant matter
but there's still things like you know
iron or selenium
or certain vitamins that need to be
produced but that's not growing at the
same rate as just the the mass of these
plants you know let me let me tell you
another story uh
look i'm not gonna pretend to be a bio
engineer or farmer or any kind of you
know
agriculturalist but i was in new zealand
and we were
we were driving from auckland to
wellington
and on the way there we drove through
this area where it looked fairly barren
and the new zealanders i was with told
me that
at one point when settlers came to new
zealand they were having their their
sheep graze in this area
but the sheep all started dropping dead
their their their livestock would just
die
randomly for no reason no idea why and
then eventually they started testing the
ground and they found there was no
selenium
i think that's what he said i think it's
selenium not a scientist guys
but uh they realized that the animals
weren't getting a vital nutrient even
though they were eating
grass and crops and things they needed
so that's it's possible that we're we're
growing all this food and we're not
putting anything into it it's just like
dry carbs
and even according to uh you know peak
prosperity they were talking about
selenium
being very important for your body to
fight off covet
and a lot of people being deficient in
it i'm actually on this website medical
news today and they recommend foods that
actually increase your testosterone it's
actually a lot of the stuff that i you
know
have been taking myself and they
recommend foods like ginger
leafy greens fatty foods fish oil virgin
olive oil
onions and oysters mediterranean diets
yeah
as positive foods to boost your
testosterone naturally because i know a
lot of people
who either go down to mexico or even
through weird doctors here in the united
states decide to do it the artificial
way
and that's why there's a lot of people
on testosterone replacement therapy
and once you're on it you're going to
have to be on it for the rest of your
life i know a lot of people who are
miserable because of it
they're very happy when they initially
take it but it's just like any other
hormone your body stops naturally
producing it so essentially you have to
inject yourself almost like steroids
every every month yeah that's exactly
what it is
that's what a lot of fighters are you
know accused of doing that's why they
test a lot of fighters because a lot of
fighters inject themselves with
anabolic steroids extra testosterone to
make sure that they're better fighters
there was even legal testosterone
replacement that joe rogan was talking
about some ufc fighters using
and then just bulking up being buffer
having huge muscles and being incredible
fighters
which also was banned by the ufc and
other fighting organizations because of
obviously people were abusing it and
taking a whole bunch of it themselves
but
uh i know a lot of people that just you
know they they take it artificially
um and uh that's that's becoming more
and more prevalent
among older men let me read this segment
from the four second hard-on
they say they are not freaks they are
the new normal of the buzzfeed trey guys
a very sizable percentage of millennial
men suffer from low testosterone levels
the reasons are pretty well known but
hard to combat modern lifestyle is
sedentary
and the most lucrative jobs in the
modern economy require sitting in front
of a computer under fluorescent lighting
for 10 hours a day
the male body requires routine athletic
activity and exposure to sunlight
and most are not getting it on top of
that processed foods and chemical
pollutants crippling men's hormone
systems
the near universal youth of birth
control pill by women results in the
water supply being tainted with estrogen
hell
male fish in polluted rivers are
actually becoming
female you mean to tell me to turn the
freaking fish
into women that's correct what kind of
website did you find four second
hard on popular science hold on
popular science.com something in the
water is feminizing male fish
are we next i've heard that the
pharmaceuticals in the water is
devastating well it's not just
pharmaceuticals we have to understand
even even cocaine
in parts of the united kingdom were
found amongst fish because of people
using record numbers of cocaine
and then it being disposed of in your
body through your stool
it going through of course the natural
kind of plants it it never filters
through
and of course it's spreading spreading
everywhere and this is also the same
for uh what's the pill that women take
not to get pregnant
birth control birth control yes birth
control so
so there also is a lot of discussion
about the larger effects of birth
control going into the water because
there's no way of filtering it out and
of course this affecting people who
drink the tap water they're the pilots
celebrating the tap water so i only
drink bottled water microplastics
we also work there's a reason i got a
glass bottled water thing i got a glass
bottle here for a reason
that's true we're in a well system here
with like an insanely good water
treatment system
and so i was wondering about you know
contaminants in water and how it's
affecting people
so obviously there's fluoride which uh i
i remember this like decades ago
they would say you know people like alex
jones and lukews of the world
chemical waste byproduct saying don't
ingest fluoride but it's in your
toothpaste so people ingest it no matter
what
it's in your water so you no matter what
you do you ingest it but there are a lot
of people saying it's conspiracy theory
it's fine
then i remember i posted something on
myspace like this is back in the day
where i read a study came out this was
back in the in the audience or whatever
you want to call it
about how fluoride does cause problems
and you shouldn't ingest it
even if like the idea is it helps your
teeth you don't need to drink it
but outside of the fluoride thing that's
a long-standing complaint people have
some jurisdictions are voting to remove
fluoride from their water
you have uh the other contaminants of
birth control pills so this is something
we've read a lot about
and now we have this this study popular
science bring pointing out
let me read a little bit as they say
it's one thing to worry about pollutants
in our fresh water supply
it's another to find out that all across
the country male fish swimming in some
of that water are becoming
intersex they're male sex organs
producing immature female eggs
although the condition occurs naturally
in some species it shouldn't happen to
black bass
but a new study shows that it is and in
numbers far greater than ever suspected
the phenomenon raises serious concerns
about the pollution levels in our rivers
and could threaten several species it's
saying the nine-year study conducted by
the u.s geological survey
provides the first nationwide count of
intersex fish in the us and us rivers
overall 44 of the large mouth and
smallmouth bass dissected
turned out to be intersect but at some
sites
91 of them of the male largemouth bass
were affected
biologist joe ellen hinks team found
intersex
males at 34 of 111 sites in eight out of
nine major river basins
including the columbia the colorado and
the mississippi the southeastern u.s was
hit hardest with intersex bass at
every location sampled along the
apalachicola savannah
and pd rivers now we need to figure out
why
the discovery raises some tough
questions scientists don't know whether
the growing number of feminized fish
could hinder reproduction enough to
disturb the rest of the ecosystem or
even drive bass
into extinction even scarier the culprit
is still unknown
the prime suspect our toilets previous
research indicates that wastewater
treatment plants flush
endocrine disruptive compounds edcs
including pharmaceuticals pesticides and
hormones into the rivers
even minuscule amounts of edcs can
trigger powerful hormonal shifts
that deform male fish's reproductive
organs during a seven year study for
instance
scientists added parts per trillion
amounts the levels emitted by treatment
plants
of synthetic estrogen used in birth
control pills to a closed lake
the resulting sex changes collapsed the
entire fish population
was alex jones right about atrazine
turning the freaking frogs gay
he wasn't wrong that's one of the few
things he wasn't right actually no he
wasn't right he admits that too right
he wasn't making that it was it was
altering the world i was specifically
talking about the chemicals
he was right about in the the water not
being filled he was talking about that
he was absolutely right
he said it was hyperbole when he said
gay he was actually what he meant was
that their sex organs were changing from
male to female
so yeah intersex with this popular
science article
i think the issue with what he was
talking about was that he cited atrazine
which i believe is a pesticide
and i think they later came out and said
that they don't believe attracting to
have been the main culprit
in causing some of these these changes
in the frog population
but we have this popular science article
admittedly it's it's from 10 years ago
so there may have been developments or
changes but we have only a few years ago
we're seeing
human males with testosterone levels
that should be alarming look i'm going
to say it again
no disrespect to the try guys i'm not
trying to be mean but i would just say
if your testosterone level is at 212
and someone who's 85 is at 367 i think
you need to go to a doctor for a full
screening of some sort something might
be wrong
they're victims i mean i feel bad for
them i don't think they did this
purposely i mean it's just
it's just the byproduct of society i
mean i think we're gonna wake up one day
in the plot of
what's that movie uh children of men
yeah you're not gonna be able to have
kids anymore i mean i think that's where
we're heading i mean it's like
and no one's gonna see it coming because
we're so focused infertility is on the
rise in western countries
and it's terrifying the stories that we
hear about and also combined with of
course the mainstream media push telling
you
you don't need children right children
are bad cultural children when you could
have a video game and there was even
advertisements i believe in the united
kingdom that were saying choose
and it was a condom and a video game and
a baby
and it's like are you are you kidding me
like like why is there such a weird push
why is there such
conversations like this happening in
other countries like poland and hungary
they're like hey we got to deal with
this somehow
uh what did the georgia guide stones say
um
keep the population of the world at 500
million did you ever see
i'm not hold on i'm not i'm not saying
that you know there's a a cabal secretly
you know stopping people from having
kids but i do think it's fair to say
that there are a lot of
environmentalists
who flat out say having kids is bad for
the planet did you see that
that grasshopper that got a fungus in
its brain and then the fungus started
controlling it and then broke out of its
body
that's the basis of that video game the
uh the cordyceps the last of us
real are we being mind controlled like
are these people saying this stuff
it could be well come on coca-cola
commercials are mind control right
that's also true
and the fungus the fungus is going to
take over coca-cola is not spraying your
house with spores that we don't want
your brain to make that we know
we don't make you drink coca-cola but i
think it's fair to say that there
are activists who think it's wrong to
have kids
and so they will absolutely use their
donations and their power to say
having kids is bad for the planet now
they're not completely wrong but i think
many of them can be completely crazy
there there is a point at which you know
growth can't be infinite
you know we used to have seven kids
families are sorry to interrupt because
we
because people would die off at age 23
or in child well no no no no no no no no
no no no we we had so
we had to just say birth control is bad
have as many kids as you can because we
need to populate the plan
the reason the reason families had so
many kids and this in this tracks in
modern times
is due to your ability to get jobs done
so
with any so there's actually this really
interesting graph showing
the development levels of certain
countries and the amount of kids people
have per family
so in africa for instance they still
have very large families because they
don't have
access to cars machines yeah right
machines necessarily and so
they need people they need people to do
jobs but as
a any any country or civilization
becomes more technologically developed
they begin having less and less kids
part of its developmental and changes in
economics but i also
think if you look at like polls and you
look at opinion polling there's a lot of
people you know younger generations that
still say they want
you know a decent sized family but they
can't have it through economic reasons
or
lack of being able to find partners and
that comes down to the mass psychology
and social economic issues
issues but also i mean what we were
talking about before with um
i lost my train of thoughts yeah but but
very interestingly there's a lot of
internationalists or or globalists there
are elites that want this and
and elites who usually like global
warming as well individuals like ted
turner who have a number of children
that advocate for their
child policy that complement china on
their one child policy that is wrecking
havoc on their society and there's also
hold on hold on
there's also individuals like prince
philip that literally were talking about
dreaming of being reincarnated as a
virus so they could create a pandemic
so they could rid the world of
overpopulation and the whole
ted turner didn't he he personally saw
to the creation of captain planet didn't
he
it's like this this neo-malthusian like
fear of the population growth which has
been disproven we've always the
technology has risen we've been able to
get
better crop yields to feed more people
as you were talking about earlier but i
do think that there is like a sort of
uh malevolence in some of the elites in
society who are
scared of growing populations growing
populations are harder to control
i was right by the way ted turner
created the environmental themed
animated series captain planet and the
planeteers
a show where like the villains are the
polluters i i like game planet
i like that show i watch this i like the
message i like i like pride in the
environment
of course but that's not what they're
doing when you only say
overpopulation is a problem in the
western world but not in other parts
of the world and you only focus on one
specific area telling them not to have
children
you got to start asking yourself what's
really kind of going on here uh
you know because again it's just odd it
doesn't add up it's nonsensical
we don't have to jump to conspiracies
but we have to acknowledge first that it
happens and it does
right we're already below replacement
level so there's no excuse
for for wanting to lower we need
natalism we need like what they're doing
in eastern europe where they're
i think hungary they just came out with
a study that showed their policies
for natalism and hungary actually worked
and within like two years the birth
rates jumped i don't know if you guys
saw that
what is natalism like promoting birth
they did that in poland
too and it's i'm not i'm not i'm not
entirely convinced we need to tell
people they have to have kids
well they want to because i feel like
people do want to but they don't have
the means to
i think i think i think i i think the
idea is to be more neutral is if people
want to have kids we should be like
okay and if people don't have kids we
say okay that's fine yeah and i i do
think
there was a chart i saw someone post
where uh we're talking about these
these stocks going up gamestop and then
someone posted something like i keep
seeing all these posts about stocks and
it's the only one i'm concerned about
and it shows human population over the
past 300 years and it's a straight line
and then
around the 1900 goes boom straight up
from you know a couple hundred years ago
400 million to
billions today so there's a there's a
real conundrum i suppose
and there's a real political argument
where there's there are a lot of people
say overpopulation's a myth
but then you look at what chris
martinson was saying about insect
population depletion
we talked about dead zones in the ocean
we talk about real environmental issues
we have uh drought problems there's not
enough water in certain areas anymore
because the rainfall isn't there so
they're doing desalination
which destroys the ocean floor wiping
out the food for everybody
so there is a point at which we upset
the balance we destroy everybody here's
the problem
what's the solution like advocating for
people
i'm sorry the solution is usually
brought to us by the same people causing
those problems
you know individuals like john kerry
that are talking about
they need to use a private jet to accept
their awards all over the world and fly
around
everywhere privately because he's going
to make
everyone else offset their co2 this kind
of benevolence elitism
elitism this kind of this kind of
thinking that you're better off than
other people
is the thinking of individuals like
prince philip that or ted turner that
openly call for eugenics and population
control well very few people want to be
evil they don't want to see themselves
as the bad guy so they will go through
the
the ringer to justify whatever actions
they're promoting under the guise of
environmentalism protecting the little
guy whatever it is it's like this
paternalism that they need to do
just to mask what really is horrible
policy decisions so
i have this uh article from yahoo and my
monitor just fell
what the heck there we go i got it back
and uh it says
kerry defended taking private jet to
iceland for environmental award
the only choice for somebody like me and
luke's right
this is my problem i want to save the
planet i like captain planet guys can we
use our magic rings to summon the
superhero dude who takes out the
polluters and the corruption it sounds
awesome doesn't it
but these people who are claiming that
they're captain planet and the
planeteers are the ones taking the
private jets in the first place
so i feel like when they come to me and
say this planet is in serious danger we
need your support to stop flushing your
toilet stop taking showers turn your
lights off
no more air conditioning and i'm going
to be in my mansion over there with 80
rooms my private jet helicopter playing
video
games with the ac set to 30 degrees
that's al gore
al gore is one of the largest kind of uh
uh
hypocrites out there uh you know in so
many realms of this so is bill gates who
also routinely calls for population
control did the obamas just buy like
beachfront property exactly
beachfront property like the oceans are
going to rise and wipe everybody out
bill gates is one of the largest farm
land owners
in the united states and he's telling
everyone that there's too much people in
this world
self-projecting their own sins onto the
population at large it's all it is and
they're just trying to mask their own
crimes what if they're right but they're
also evil i don't think and that's right
and the issue is hypothetically we are
dealing with
fishery collapses ocean dead zones mass
pollution in the oceans
and their mentality is if we only if we
could only make everyone else stop doing
it we can live in london
this myth has been going on for decades
i mean there was always they've always
moved the goal post like i mentioned
malthus earlier every time that they
always say we're going to hit a critical
mass in terms of population
technology catches up awareness in
society catches up
and it pushes the upper limit i mean yes
there may be a point where we plateau
but so far it's always the goal posts
keep moving yeah yeah you're not going
to stop people from behaving
you people are going to keep taking
craps they're going to keep throwing
things on the ground when they're done
with them that's
that's what we do and it's stuff's going
to end up in the ocean so we'll have to
look at people like boy and slat who
will regret i was just thinking about it
i was just thinking about i was looking
him up this is crazy these people are
going to tell you to stop and
cut back on the amount of humans and to
stop but no we're going to keep wasting
and we're going to keep growing but
people like boyan and us we can re
collect the plastic convert it back into
oil and reuse it and then take the
carbon dioxide out of the air but
let me poison pointing out real quick i
saw this very important fact from
cassandra
fairbanks that walt disney was obsessed
with making you know disneyland or world
i don't know which one
functioned perfectly and so they did a
study on how many steps a person will
take before they litter
and they found it was like 30 so they
put a trash can every trash can is
within at least 29 steps of every other
trash can and there's no litter
that was it yeah yeah boiling slot i'm
so happy you brought him up he's one of
the youngest members to be ever
invited to bilderberg i remember
pounding the airports right and
and seeing him and all the other
reporters like he's not bilderberg i'm
like yes he is
and i just had a feeling confronted him
he he was there at the bilderberg
conference one of the youngest people
he's the one that's building
these huge rafts in the ocean that
collect all the plastic and actually
is a big effort in cleaning up the
oceans i actually interviewed him
after bilderberg he said some really
surprising and interesting stuff but but
he's doing something he's creating a
technology
as you were saying solving a lot of
these bigger problems instead of just
creating them like a lot of these elites
right that's why it's it's not a problem
it's going to self-correct i mean this
is
if you could go back through history
there's always been points where at some
point human development has started to
push back on its own development
and itself corrects it returns to
equilibrium so the ingenuity of this guy
is part of that you can kind of like
redirect the flow of the waste river
of humanity of what we are by like
placing trash cans every 30 feet
and so we don't throw on the ground we
throw the trash can it's still going to
end up from that trash can in a landfill
or in the ocean
so we need to do things like what
buoyant's doing and we don't collect the
plastic i don't think so
maybe you guys your initial assessment
was correct that life adapts
because i have another story for you
from eco watch scientists find bacteria
that eats plastic
they say german researchers have
identified a strain of bacterium that
not only breaks down toxic plastic
but also uses it as food to fuel the
process
according to the guardian the scientists
discovered the strain of bacteria known
as
pseudomonas bacteria at a dump site
loaded with plastic waste
where they noticed that it was attacking
polyurethane polyurethanes are
ubiquitous in plastic products because
they are pliable and durable
however when they reach the end of their
usefulness and end up in landfills they
decompose slowly
and slowly release toxic chemicals into
the soil as they degrade
they are also notoriously difficult to
recycle since it is so difficult to
recycle millions and millions of
products containing them
sneakers diapers kitchens sponges etc
end up in landfills
quote the bacteria can use these
compounds as a sole source of carbon
nitrogen and energy herman j high piper
a senior scientist
at the helmholtz center for
environmental research ufc in leipzig
germany co-author of the new paper said
in a statement these findings represent
an important step
in being able to reuse hard to recycle
polyurethane products
perhaps we invented something out of
sync
with the natural ecosystem plastics and
it
took a certain amount of time before
something emerged that adapted to eat it
and there's
possible things there's also a fungus
microspore that develops devours
plastic really breaks down to sugar i
mean earth is way more durable than we
think it is and we have this arrogance
that humans are just going to be this
destructive thing but if we're natural
to this earth eventually it's going to
return to equilibrium like i said
earlier so i think it's a great white
pill so it's good to hear well
one more thing too we even have this
other story from 2018 an oil eating
bacterium that can clean up pollution
and spills
eats eats petroleum eats the oil that
that leaks they these things adapt and
credit
i don't want to be overly optimistic and
kick my feet back and be like we're
going to do anything
just let it go life takes care of itself
but it does seem that we could be
optimistic and these these people who
claim
we must sacrifice our lives our
livelihoods and our businesses
so they can have private jets might
actually be lying to us 100 percent
we should be optimistic because that's
the only real way to move forward in a
solution based reality
uh and another thing that you're talking
about specifically here with a lot of
these
people that are big global warming
proponents a lot of them right now
there's there's articles
there's there's research happening right
now with people saying
in this space like hey you know with
these coveted restrictions a lot less
people are moving around there a lot
less people are traveling a lot less
people are actually
causing global warming they're not
driving everywhere this is good and
maybe we should keep these restrictions
for the benefit of the policy
sacky today she said uh you get the
vaccines you still have to where the
masters still have the social distance
they're not going to give this up they
want to return to like a neo-feudal
society where you stay in your little
village you stay in your little
nine to five you don't travel you don't
see the world you're isolated that's
that's the best thing for them
and they'll hide behind environmentalism
to get us there keeping people isolated
accelerates internet ideologies that
they can control
exactly so if people can't interact in
real life and when you go online
they control what opinions you're
allowed to see they are
mass social engineering the culture of
the united states and the world
whether we whether whether it's
intentional or not it's literally
happening agreed did you see uh
since we've been locked down the
temperature on earth has gone up 0.1 to
0.3 percent
what yeah still global warming it wasn't
humans
or at least so there's been multiple ice
ages
we're coming out of an ice age now we're
in an integra let's talk about the last
ice age
let's talk about the censorship issues
and because of the lockdown
the mass social engineering i have the
story from theblaze.com now i emphasize
the blaze
this is glenn beck conservative
host of progressive media accounts claim
they've been arbitrarily demonetized by
youtube
widespread crackdown question mark the
longest time i was conservatives
who were getting nuked predominantly and
now it seems to be swallowing up many
progressives
they're not going after the
establishment elite types though they're
going after those who criticize joe
biden
the blaze says several independent
progressive media personalities spoke
out recently claiming their youtube
accounts
were arbitrarily censored by the video
platform for publishing or covering
content deemed harmful
independent journalist caitlyn johnstone
first reported on the news further
advancing speculation
that the google-owned video company is
engaging in a widespread content
crackdown johnstone wrote in a blog post
wednesday
that progressive commentators graham
elwood the progressive soapbox
the convo couch frank analysis hannah
reloaded and cyber
even 531 have all received notifications
from youtube that their videos are no
longer permitted to earn money through
the platform's various monetization
features
as has ford fisher a respected
freelancer who films u.s political
demonstrations
what we're seeing right now again
whether intentional or not
we can't go to the bar we can't go to
restaurants and talk to talk to other
people on the ground
all we can do is go on twitter and see
the radicalization
you can see them screaming your face
over and over again insurrection
insurrection insurrection
i know people in chicago who have no
business in politics people who spend
their lives just like working behind a
bar at a bar and don't care for politics
and they love football
all of a sudden now the only thing they
talk about is why trump was bad and why
we need all of this far left policy
because the only social interactions
they're actually having are online
now i will take this moment to stress
you didn't think they were going to come
for progressives a lot of people thought
it was only going to be conservatives
the reality is
most of us who are advocating for free
speech including many conservatives said
they will come for you they don't like
you so go to timcast.com become a member
and provide us that shield because they
will ban us
i'm my facebook was shut down i was just
on the convo couch one of the ones they
listed who are great guys super leftists
they they were working with me they were
talking about they loved what we did
down and reoccupied they were actually
trying to work towards a solution they
weren't controlled opposition like aoc
but you go back to history i mean the
second the communists take over the
first people they kill are the
intellectuals the academics
all the true believers they don't need
them anymore who fomented the revolution
in the first place exactly
a threat to their exactly exactly the
trotsky's whatever and i remember
getting demonetized a few years ago
and a lot of people you know kind of
celebrating it i'm like this is going to
hit you and i've been saying this for
years i've been we were even talking
about this point this exact point just a
few weeks ago saying that a lot of the
leftists are going to get hit soon
especially with the establishment coming
in
it's happening no longer needing them
and no longer needing them and and i
even tweeted today i feel sorry this
happened and i
and i think they should be censored even
though i don't believe what they believe
in it doesn't matter the principle still
stands
the ideas should be fought through
better ideas
and sadly that's not happening and it's
devastating when you get demonetized i
know a lot of companies independent
media that haven't come back from it
that can't operate anymore don't operate
anymore
and many times they are a lot better
than the trash and the division
than the agenda that they're pushing on
the mainstream media and we're going to
have less and less of that
i got i got real mad today because we're
getting news about these stimulus checks
they're they're now going to means test
them so joe biden the democrats told
everybody vote the democrats get them in
and you're going to get two grand then
they said well we actually mean 14
hundred it's a supplement to the 600 you
already got and then i rolled my eyes i
was like okay okay fine fine i get it
many progressives are outraged
now they're saying well i mean we didn't
mean everyone we just meant 1400
checks to those who make less than 50k a
year which is
it keeps changing now that's important
for people
it's going to affect your life what was
cnn talking about all day
no matter taylor green what was on
what's the top headline story for
everybody what's all they're talking
about is marjorie taylor green i don't
care
no disrespect to her i know the left
wants to bring it
i don't know a whole lot about her i
think she said dumb things but she's a
freshman congresswoman
she is not of that much political
consequence for them to to just
trying to hammer in but you know it is
it is what i was saying how they how
they isolate us
then they hammer in these ideas which
tribe are you in
they say you know she's bad right you
must denounce her right the republicans
go right along with it they voted
11 republicans voted to strip over
committees this is what we're getting
instead of being told about why we're
being shut down why we're being
strangled out why our businesses are
destroyed
they're saying look at the nasty mean
person on the internet
i i don't care they've perfected social
engineering i mean it's like you know
bread and circuses
like you said the social isolation i
mean it's coming down to a science in
terms of how they're controlling people
and i'm meeting people in my day-to-day
life that are just completely hysterical
over coveted fears
they're just dehumanizing without
controlling people but making them
mentally
mentally ill you're right it's a mental
illness absolutely right i think a lot
of these representatives
that are supposed to be representing us
suffer from narcissistic personality
disorder
i mean everything is me me me look at
what i did look at this and
and this is a textbook definition and
they keep forgetting they're supposed to
be representing the people who are
actually struggling out there and
they're not doing that right right
exactly well i can only imagine it's
going to get worse
if they're coming for progressives that
means they're the
the the path which we can walk on online
on youtube on twitter is getting ever
narrower yeah but water flows whether
there's a path for it or not so
if if they try and stifle this path
another one will be formed
we're we talk about it almost daily
that's why i built you know that's why
we are all building timcast.com
and encouraging people to join because
something i should have done a long time
ago i mean i had the website but it was
just some like generic website that like
rehosted videos
now we're doing exclusive content and
trying to actually actually build
something out
probably was dumb of us not to do a long
time ago to realize that we can't rely
on other people's platforms when they're
massive monopolistic
and they have insane views and they ban
people for insane reasons and of course
they're going to ban us at some point
that's why you can't give up because if
if everything was working they wouldn't
need the propaganda they wouldn't need
the gas lighting
they wouldn't need all this this massive
disinformation they're obviously worried
that's why they keep moving the new
horizons i'm sure they're going to come
after
your website now to get you de-listed
with either the domains or the servers
or whatever it is so
the goal posts are moving in a good way
but it's also it's it's we're in a
constant chase essentially
one of these individuals who got
demonetized has a really excellent video
that says tim poole just about creams
his pants over capital
what does it say capital building riot
oh okay i'm i'm
sure this looks like it's a really old
video too that has nothing to do with
wow it looks like she faked it because
there's a video of me in philadelphia
and i haven't we haven't been there in a
very long time in fact it's the
it's the old set from 2018. so i'm
wondering what that has to do with
anything having to do with the riot and
she's showing clips
that's maybe that's why she got she got
banned maybe maybe the reality is some
of these people just make fake content
there are some bad apples and they
deserve to be called out a hundred
percent there's a lot of snake oil
salesmen that that
do things that are not genuine that are
not good but when you compare the
the harm to mainstream media it's
absolutely nothing
and if we're going to scrutinize
independent media let's scrutinize all
media including the mainstream media at
least make it fair at least make it a
free market where
the same rules apply to everyone they
don't the there's different rules
applying to this channel
my channel and all the other independent
media channels out there
and mainstream media doesn't need to
play by all any of them they could show
whatever they want
there's cnn individuals
[Music]
massive issue that it really wasn't and
they used it as their you know cassius
belly to declare war on independent
media outlets independent journalists
because anyone who could be promoting
anything outside the orthodoxy outside
the establishment's narrative
must be promoting dangerous conspiracy
theories or anything that's wrong think
so so this this this guy reza aslan
outrages hindus by eating human brains
in cnn documentary he
he really did this he went to india and
cnn is on tv
this guy is still a verified user on
these platforms he was posting extremely
messed up things with the covington kids
this guy routinely posts inflammatory
and and and damn near incitement like
when
you know let's just put it that way i
think there's been a few instances where
people were shocked that
twitter didn't ban him or take his stuff
down he's been accused many times of
threatening violence against individuals
because of their political ideas
you know i i do i do think that i mean
this sincerely i think eating the brain
maybe broke his psyche i don't no no i
don't mean like he ate the brain in it
and it poisoned him i mean
you can't come back from that but his t
levels are through the roof right but
you know listen listen
he did something on tv it's almost like
he was sitting there and the camera was
on and they were like do it eat the
brain come on you want to be you want to
be able to you know you probably had a
cnn producer being like well you know
you want
the show you want to do good i want
ratings i wouldn't be surprised if he
has ptsd
and he broke down and cried afterwards
because they pushed him beyond what
humans
a regular human can do i think the
cannibal grabbed him or like like threw
him down and started yelling no no no he
didn't
i thought he was trying to get up no no
no no the cannibal was acting wild and i
think did aggress
at him in some way but he chose to eat
the brain voluntary got it and it was it
was a small piece of charred brain that
he eats
and i don't think eating the brain gave
him like what was it
what is it called encephalopathy is that
what is uh does it give you
the shakes i don't think it like
poisoned him i think it
mentally broke him and now he's
basically like lost it from eating brain
it was the trauma it wasn't so much what
i ate yeah yeah because like imagine
you're in this situation where you're
powerless
you have a company you have a contract
to say do it you have to it's your
contract eat the brain
and then you're like i guess i have to
and then you do it you can never come
back from that for the rest of his life
the dude's a cannibal he could have
taken down cnn
just been like these guys wanted me to
become a cannibal on air and like you
know that would have been the end of
them but he's a cannibal
he is a cannibal yeah but and and and
you know i know we're kind of derailing
but
he's become this really vile individual
on the internet
and we talked about the the mind virus
how people are just
really nasty and demoralized and what
he's doing
is absolutely a very large component of
the nastiness and i have to wonder if
what we saw from him eating brain is a
really good example of how
a lot of people feel on lower levels
they feel they're forced to say these
things
they have no choice how many people
genuinely agree there was a woman
who posted you know she was voting for
all white people white people to be put
on a barge and kicked out to sea
and a white guy responded with like oh
man i would volunteer for that and it's
like
does he really agree with that or does
he cry himself to bed at night
while he literally advocates for himself
being exiled on a boat
stockholm syndrome like it's just like
look at the self-hate look at the
the disparaging this this nasty
self-harm that's being glory
you know glorized on the on the media
it's a virtue
on social media that that it this is
somehow a good thing
right it's it's not you should be
confident you should respect yourself
because only when you respect yourself
you could only then truly respect others
and until you start having
you know confidence and and love and
compassion for yourself how can you have
it for anyone else they've tied social
status to either being a victim or
either just being you know self-hating
for the most part and that's
you rise to the ranks of society if
you've had so many different traumatic
experience that you can you know like
like aoc basically using your sexual
assault when questioned on policy issues
i mean that's what's happening society
there's no there's no virtue anymore and
there's no social uh status assigned to
being
an independent healthy free thinking
adult it's a sign of being a child
exactly or
yeah a follower it's just it's not a
child or it's your follower account it's
your likes it's your retweets
your ratings so this guy's social credit
right this guy and now it's visible so
this guy rezla my opinion on this brain
eating thing was that vice was really
big
and they were like you want to beat vice
right you want to be big because i
i'll tell you this when i left vice i
probably had a thousand people
say what can we do to to get that you
know that kind of
zeal that kind of enthusiasm that kind
of coolness that edginess
so he along comes this dude and he ate
human brain
i feel like that is the the apex of
desperation for social acceptance he
wanted to be cool and edgy like vice he
wanted to fit in and have a big show
with tons of ratings and be famous so he
literally ate
human brain he could never come back for
that it broke him
and now the reason i hammer that point
is think about the more
the the smaller instances where people
do this do this stuff the false
accusations
the the defense of people the the you
know the people who pile on say
attacking brett kavanaugh when come on
what sane people thought those
allegations about him lining up outside
of a dormitory
game rapes gang raping women that's the
most insane thing i've ever heard
but these people have no force of will
so what happens is
you know people like us probably
everybody in this room if someone said
eat a brain we'd be like
no and they'd be like well everyone will
make fun of you if you don't know but i
don't care i'm not eating brain
but then you have the other portion of
society where they're like is it the
only way to fit in
okay i'll do it you know firsthand i
worked in los angeles and hollywood in
the entertainment industry for like
10 years and i would do these
commercials like and i'd go and read and
they'd be like okay
just say i don't care what's in it it
tastes great
and it was everything i didn't believe
and i would do it for the money
and i started to become such a nasty
person it was because i hated myself
for those that that stupid stuff i would
say that i didn't believe and i could
totally see these these
these people doing it not only with
their actions but with their words which
are type of apps but when you hate
yourself you're a good consumer
because you always need to fill that
empty void inside of yourself with empty
chinese-made trinkets
made by slaves bought on credit credit
exactly wouldn't then
it be not a bad thing to get all of
these mass
consumer lunatics to stop buying stuff
like the people who fulfill themselves
by
eating brain to prove their worth or
buying things they don't need
shouldn't we be encouraging people to
roll up their sleeves and go chop some
wood
but go outside go outside stop you know
fill up your gas tank stop buying butane
literally just
take some wood cut it up into bits do
the hard work and enjoy the fire with
your friends outside
this goes full circles we were talking
about earlier there's no transcendence
in society no one's living for a higher
purpose than themselves it's like this
hyper-individualistic
hedonistic you know pleasure
self-serving that just corrupts all of
society because really the basis of
society it's not really the individual
it should really be the family
the family unit or some kind of group
structure but that's why they're trying
to atomize everyone you know live in
your pod eat your bugs that whole kind
of shtick it's it's disgusting yeah it's
well it's
it's mentally deranged self-absorbed
lunatics and
i'm to me that's the definition of a
congressman uh
i'm sorry yes because when you look at
their kind of activities you look
congress woman that's right whatever
potato
potato
uh when you look at what they're doing
they're doing the most insidious
ridiculous things to get the most amount
of eyeballs the most amount of attention
that
generates money that generates clicks
that generates you being in a position
of power
they are extremely privileged they are
extremely empowered and for these people
to be on national television playing
like they're the victims
that they're traumatized i mean give me
a break i think it's even more so for
celebrities which are like
neo-aristocrats and so many people look
to them more than they do you know the
congresswoman like aoc who is a
celebrity in their own right but
they're the ones who take all these
different impulses in society that we're
talking about and put them on steroids
and they're just even heightened i mean
that's why you see the most ridiculous
cases in like page six or whatever it is
because it's just a never-ending cycle
to outdo the previous more
insane instance of whatever it is you in
order to earn points you got to one you
got to one up the next and it's kind of
like you got to eat human brain
because because of desperation i think
people like your average person are
seeking like attention so that they can
get some money to survive or some
resources or some
attention is kind of a resource too i
think it's because we removed religion
sorry i didn't mean to cut you off
and continue um so politicians are
trying to placate that
desperation by with these social
programs
and it's not working but then it's this
this conversation i feel like is is
becoming circular because it's like
throughout human history we've always
been desperate to survive
we don't we're not owed a living you
know we have to go out and
take it and and it's we've always been
competing to survive against wild
animals or against other humans maybe
i'll i'll say this
we broke ourselves away from that where
now we
as americans especially europeans but
all over the world people who live in
luxury
don't have to fight to survive you you
wake up you know there's food
everywhere an insane amount first world
problems yeah first world problems
are all we really have shouldn't people
get back
shouldn't like should there's a
threshold we met where we can survive
now
can't people just be happy sitting under
the stars with their friends and their
family smiling and
climbing trees we made it animals don't
kill us randomly now
but what i mean is like i think i think
most of us here really enjoy
the outdoors starting a fire ian ian
loves working out ways to start fires on
his own yeah but when i was really poor
i i was hard to love anything i was
obsessed with where am i gonna
get my am i gonna be able to pay rent am
i going to be out on the street next
month
can i afford why do i have to eat this
junk because i can't afford better food
and it was terrible i think the better
food thing is a myth actually because i
was poor and i ate decently well there's
always going to be i was probably not i
mean
really good now we we buy the best in
such a huge variety of
oils and vinegars and lots of vinegar
like vegetables that all of anything we
want we have access to i'll be honest
because of that i can enjoy the little
things i don't think we eat the best i
mean we literally have like bacon and
bread you know what i mean it's not like
we're having filet mignon every night or
something i feel very appreciative
i i feel luke wants me to order those
what peter luger luger steaks
because of our position existing
honestly we've
i've made sure that we have access to
all the nutrients we need
and it's sure sure i i definitely i
definitely can understand i'm one of
those people that enjoys the little
things like i can sit in a room
and with a book and just be happy for
days that's what i mean i mean
you've got a lot of people who live in
cities who are desperate to fit in with
their tribe to earn those social media
points
so i'm not saying like obviously you
know we have a successful business and
we're
privileged in that regard but even you
know when i was
broke and living on couches my
fulfillment didn't come from owning
stuff
it came from experience with my friends
going in skateboarding getting that new
trick
and just going on adventures to new
places even if it was just walking down
the tracks to see where the tracks went
so many people now are tied to
fulfillment from getting other people to
say they like them
to prove it or to own something to prove
they've got
their car because if they lose their car
life gets harder and they don't want to
lose their i mean when i started my news
organization i literally
was you know not having any money couch
surfing everywhere i had to sleep on the
floor sometimes and it was amazing i had
the best time of my life traveling all
over the world all over the united
states hitching rides
uh hitchhiking here's literally
hitchhiking
uh you know there's so many places and
it was incredible i want to tell people
your deep your your secret to success
dude literally just got on a speed boat
went to epstein island yeah anyone could
have done it yeah
there's a couple journalists that like
literally went around it but like we had
this amazing captain that just surprised
us
wait let me hold on i'm sorry i gotta
clarify luke went to epstein island to
document yes
yes yes yes yes please please please no
misconceptions
i wasn't an invitee yeah i wasn't
invited i came here to expose the story
yeah
where is where's the sense of adventure
where people are satisfied by just
exploring the woods going for a walk and
like
looking at flowers that's why there's so
much nostalgia in in society because all
the things you remember when you were
kids exploring the woods all that sense
of adventure and unknown it doesn't
exist in the modern world as an adult
anymore for the most part so there's so
much nostalgia in society
i mean you see it everywhere it does
though yeah it literally does
what do you mean you could you could
look man i'll tell you
you live in new york yeah uh has is
there a burr you've never been to
is there a what a borough you've never
been to no you you've been all the bros
yeah
have you uh walked every block of staten
island i have not no
you could literally go for a walk
through staten island and i i chose that
on purpose because
yeah i don't think i would sleep because
nobody nobody wants i do know someone
who went
every block in manhattan and they
documented it was a very cool cool thing
but it's rare
it's very rare no i know i know people
who uh i'll be honest
most of people i knew in brooklyn had
never been to the bronx
no joke no joke or staten island yeah i
believe it definitely would have stat
now then i won't walk around on the
beach but it's like the way
i think it's it's like the mindset
because it's you can enjoy the shape of
a tree like
the tree branch and like whoa and the
light breaking through it or look at the
clouds
or you can be stressed about what's
coming up in two hours that you got to
be at that thing
so like f this tree it's like it's kind
of like we have so much information in
society you have wikipedia at your
fingertips you can get everything but
there's no interest in finding that
knowledge it's the same thing you could
travel anywhere tomorrow at least not
there's no there's no self-fulfillment
there's no drive to do it though like
i'm fulfilled independently like when i
go skate
i'm skating here for the most part by
myself sometimes adam me and adam will
be skating
but typically i'll go skate you know the
mini ramp and i'll decide what tricks i
want to do for me
by myself and i'm fulfilled by doing it
but i don't look to satisfaction from
any other person like
that book bowling alone with the
basically the fall of like american kind
of the
the town and the community and a lot of
the stuff we're talking about it's the
guy bowling alone because it's just like
we've lost kind of bonds with
you know obviously it goes beyond just
what people think of you but there are
bonds being broken with other people
which also gives you value it's not just
always what other people think of you
but there is a benefit to having a
social network that's healthy and
productive i think we might be
too pessimistic because i think human
beings naturally have this drive
to explore and to learn but a lot of it
is just being squashed out by the school
system by government the mainstream
media and now social media that wants to
distinguish
it wants to extinguish this kind of
drive within human beings don't people
have less free time now than they did
like 50 60 years ago i remember reading
somewhere i don't i don't necessarily
agree with that
um i don't know if it's true i just
remember but it's probably true in some
context but i'll tell you the saying
goes that
a a poor person today has better dental
care than rockefeller did
at the height of you know his oral oil
bearing shift i
so badly wanted to have kids in my 20s
and travel around the world
with my wife and i didn't have the money
so i didn't
but no one could do that you know what i
mean like people could some
some people could but it doesn't mean
you're entitled to or should expect it
you know what i mean
they're they're yeah but i didn't have
kids because i couldn't afford it when
when could anyone ever afford kids
that's a myth you can afford
they're not that they're like fifty
thousand dollars a year but it it what
what about the people who literally
lived in the wilderness
and had kids it's a myth that you can't
afford
you know most people have kids don't
plan them earth because they didn't i
don't i don't think they would call them
accidents but not planned they were
there it's not like they said okay let's
have a kid in you know nine months so
let's get to it
no like people would hook up and they'd
have kids and then they would fight to
survive for their kids
i didn't like to survive i wanted to not
share it i don't know
casey neistat one of the most successful
individuals
in the new internet age had a kid i
think when he was 16
and he was living in a trailer i think
he was homeless at one point
and then he went to become one of the
greatest you know
entrepreneurs of this generation and
it's legit he revolutionized youtube
vlogging
and he had a kid well before he was
prepared or capable and he was poor as
as heck but he made it work
i think this idea that you have to have
be richer enough to do it
i i don't necessarily agree i think the
problem is are you fulfilled
internally or externally and people
mostly there's too many people in this
in this world
in this country who are looking for
satisfaction from other
they're looking for uh they're looking
to other people to validate their
existence
instead of validating it on their own
right so i i think
i made that point i do want to we don't
have a lot of time and i want to do this
next segment which is
totally the worst segue ever because
it's a totally different subject
so let's jump i don't know if you want
to add anything i don't know we're
talking about like the best conversation
on earth
well we're gonna we're i want to jump to
uh a totally unrelated story
as our final segment for tonight's show
because we got we got to do it and
dmt no i hate it when we're like we got
this thing i talk about when we don't do
it
this one is not the biggest breaking
news in the world
but i think it's a really important
story to talk about this video is going
viral
and i'll give you guys a graphic warning
oh my god trigger warning
as it were i'm gonna go use the bathroom
you know are you are you serious you
told me the story already before and you
know i don't want to be involved in the
conversation i will
i will i know what you're saying but i'm
going to go really quickly i thought
luke was bailing out i'm like no there's
a guy
no but i don't want to hear you crazy
this is a this is look i i mean this
like i'm not a big fan of the whole
trigger warnings because someone says a
naughty word
this is death this is brutal murder this
is a conversation about
some real stuff so it's not something
you want he's gonna share his trauma
with us because he watched this video
four times earlier i think i watched it
more than four times
sometimes you just gotta force yourself
to see it i i'm a firm believer in when
you get when you see
when these things are happening online
you can't hide from them all right so
let me let me tell you the story
three dead in a fight over snow man
47 shoots feuding neighbors with handgun
and rifle
for shoveling snow into his yard before
turning gun on himself
normally we've seen stories like this
people get into a fight a shooting
happens it happens all the time
this time we have full video of
everything that happened
with full audio it is graphic it is
horrifying i'm not going to play the
video but we're going to talk about
gun ownership gun rights and
this is a brutal story so let me give
the details
they say pennsylvania prosecutors ruled
monday triple shooting in plains
township
a murder suicide enclosed the case they
said jeffrey spade 47 used two firearms
to shoot and kill his across the street
neighbors james goy50
and lisa [ __ ] 48 before committing
suicide
violence broke out during a heated
argument about snow removal prosecutors
say
goys had been dumping snow in spade's
yard and when he asked them to stop the
couple began yelling obscenities at him
james [ __ ] was said to have shown spayed
his fist made threats and root gestures
spade went to his house came out with a
gun and shot the goys then retrieved an
ar-15 style rifle and fired more rounds
in the street
spade fatally shot himself inside his
home as police arrived on the scene
now like i said i'm not going to show
you images of the
actual incident i'm just going to show
you stills of before the incident so you
can get a general idea of what it looks
like
it's a security camera footage that
recorded rather clean audio
not the highest resolution there are two
people here and there were yelling
obscenities in a man across the street
calling him
uh effective effectively an emasculating
slur
that was it the dude eventually just
turns around walks inside
and he comes out with a gun and the
first thing i'll say is
you know growing up in chicago you want
to know the most frustrating thing to me
in chicago when i was with someone who's
not from chicago not from the city
road rage absolutely hate being i'd be
in the city
and i'd have a friend from the suburbs
and we'd be driving
and then someone would cut us off or do
something and they would start screaming
and flipping them off and i had a lot of
friends who would do this
you know why you don't do that in
chicago because chicago has people
who are armed illegally and will kill
you for honor
there are literally instances all the
time in chicago
where someone flicks someone else off
and it's it's some gang banger and he
says you want to get hard with me and he
pulls out his gun and he shoots the
person
i have been just driving down the street
had someone plop their gun and fire up
my car for no
reason so it is infuriating i'm like
dude
you need to learn to walk away you don't
want to fight someone because you can
get some wackaloon dude who pulls out a
gun and shoots you for
for just because of snow it happens
don't
pick fights you don't need to engage in
that's the first thing i'll say
and this video is crazy the dude pulls
up the gun and the couple across the
street
don't do anything the woman actually
starts yelling at the guy
and then he shoots him several times and
they start screaming bystanders
eventually run away no one's there to
help them the dude goes in his house
gets an ar-15 comes out and i'm sorry
this is this is a gruesome conversation
the woman on the ground
injured after being shot i believe twice
in the head he points the ar at her
he shoots her again point blank
he then walks up to the guy you can't
see the guy because he's now by the
house and he's moaning and calling for
help
and then this dude he kills him the
crazy thing about the story is
sometimes people do crazy things the guy
could have pulled out a knife or
something he could have gotten any
weapon he wanted
but i was thinking about what would have
happened if this dude this this victim
was open carrying if he had a holstered
gun on his hip
would that guy across the street
actually have come out with a gun to
confront him
or would he have been like that dude's
armed i don't want to get shot
would he have been concerned or what if
he came out with a gun and the other guy
held his gun and said drop it don't do
it
would the other guy have been like oh
man i'm going to get shot there are a
lot of questions a lot of things to
bring up in a story like this
the main reason i want to talk about it
is just because it's like
it's going viral and we actually have a
full video of the full incident
and i just it raised a lot of questions
about when you when you you
you pick your battles when you run why
these people didn't run
what were they thinking why they weren't
defending themselves
i don't know man what do you guys think
i 100 think if if he did have open carry
and he was armed
the whole dynamic sort of changed i mean
this this guy obviously went postal we
went nuts
he had this momentary uh this fleeting
moment of power he had full control over
them he probably loved it and he didn't
want to give it up and he had to go the
full way and the full way eventually
led to their deaths and his death had
there been something that prevented him
from
having that full you know kind of rush
of power that kind of high
it could have changed the dynamics no
lives have been lost
mexican standoff who knows but i think
it certainly would have changed i think
for the better
well yeah i personally grew up in new
york city and you know as a young kid i
saw a lot of gun violence
i moved to new hampshire and in new
hampshire a lot of people open carry
mainly because you're in the middle of
the woods and if there's a wildlife you
need to protect yourself this is why you
see a lot of people
having a gun on their hip when i lived
there i had a gun on my hip
everywhere i went i had no problems
everyone was very nice
everyone was very cordial uh and we and
we have to understand here that you know
having a firearm on your hip is a huge
huge responsibility
and even though i had no problems with
anyone ever
it could be it could be not a result of
having that but i remember even
you know kind of coaching myself and
talking to myself and looking up and
researching de-escalation techniques
because i know if i have a firearm
i'm going to need to do everything in my
power to de-escalate any kind of
aggressive situation
to make sure it doesn't erupt into a
violent one because i've seen in new
york city
just the slightest thing i mean i was
involved in so many fights and and
and jumps and and like crazy stuff over
the smallest
littlest pathetic issues and it all
revolved around
ego people could have walked away i
could have walked away as a young kid i
know a lot of other kids that should
have walked away they didn't it was
their ego it was their strong-headedness
that led them to a conflict
and you know i still don't know a lot of
about this
a lot about this particular story it's
extremely graphic the first time you
told me about it i didn't feel good
that's why i walked out i didn't want to
hear it again but it's a reality that we
need to understand that we need to face
but a bigger one is if i could speculate
here
you know individuals who usually do
commit such crimes at that kind of age
group
usually don't have a family usually
don't have a purpose you usually don't
have a belief in god
full circle nothing to lose and exactly
have nothing to lose and that's why this
guy
essentially ended up killing himself and
and did something incredibly wrong
that you know if he had a belief in god
he wouldn't be doing there's probably a
lot of guys like him that are just one
bad day away from losing
and i can't say this enough if you are a
gun owner i am a gun owner
it is your responsibility to de-escalate
yeah i don't care the situation i don't
care
your ego i don't care if you have a
girlfriend and how you look in front of
everyone or how many people are watching
it is your sole duty as as someone who
is armed
to make sure that you avoid any kind of
conflict
any kind of escalation event that of
course will lead towards more violence
because when it
sparks it sparks so bad and a lot of
people are usually traumatized and left
wondering why did this happen
and it gets bad i saw it in new york
city i had friends that died
uh you know i don't want to get into
some of the stories i don't want to get
into
but uh i mean gavin you
made an interesting point about him
having the power you know he was being
called a disparaging term that was
emasculating
and so then he's like oh you want to
call me that you know he basically says
it over and over again at the guy as
he shoots him and i wonder if he didn't
actually have the power to do it not
because of cour of course he was armed
what if the other guy was armed would
that have led to him being like there's
nothing i can do the dude's armed
he'll just fire back at me was it that
he actually had
there was that imbalance of power where
he knew they could not stop him
and then he went nuts adrenaline i think
there was there was some chemicals
you know shifting through his body that
that pushed him over the edge as well
but i think also just the dynamics of
the situation also
kind of emboldened him if that's the
right word to say i mean i think that
that it's
it's a really interesting case from a
psychological standpoint i mean you're
looking at this dynamic he got you know
emasculated like you said
he was trying to preserve his honor it
seems like a little thing but
it could it could lead to bloodshed it's
all in his head yeah and people need to
understand
de-escalate like and i put myself even
through mental situations what's going
to happen if there's a road rage
incident what's going to happen if
there's an incident when someone bumps
into me
what am i going to do when i have my
firearm to make sure that this doesn't
escalate any further
and and seriously i mean i can't stress
this enough you guys if you have a
firearm
you need to do this concealed carry open
carry doesn't matter personally
you need to de-escalate this may be a
weird thing but tying it to like
bullying i think you know there's a lot
of talk that's put into bullying how to
stop it how to prevent it first of all i
think bullying is a good thing but i
think what we do wrong is that we don't
teach people how to fight back
and it creates this situation where
people can basically say nasty things to
other people
and that slowly builds up in their head
over the years so this guy probably was
who knows maybe he was bullied his whole
life and it's just been brewing in him
had we instilled in in young people if
you if someone says something to you
nasty whatever it is
fight back defend yourself you may get
you you may get beat but punch
back it creates a deterrent so no one's
going to just actively try to just mess
with other people
i think that's a little thing it's it's
a small variable in this whole thing as
a society but i do i have seen people
who've just been their whole life just
been on the receiving end of just
getting you know
just getting put down and then they they
snap we did a segment
a while back we were talking with
cassandra fairbanks about
west virginia and uh gun ownership in
these states where people are
open carrying were talking about like
living in the middle of nowhere
being armed and castle doctrine kind of
states the general idea was people don't
mess with each other because
they'll die right if you if you're
trying to break into someone's house
and probably probably new hampshire look
new hampshire's castle doctrine right i
believe so yeah
you just get shot yep so people don't do
it yep
there's an equalizing effect to where
it's like you will be a victim but when
people know that they control the power
because
i mean this guy was going to commit the
ultimate crime making me think about
social media interactions and like
you're saying
de-escalate but when you go on twitter
and you see people
say something then someone argues with
them and then it's this ego battle
and where's the de-escalation that's
what it comes to is we need to start
de-escalating online it's
he brought up a good point especially in
the kind of world star hip-hop era
and you see a lot of violence linked to
social media use
not just the the kind of mental illness
that's promoted by the algorithms that
are out there by big tech that
manipulate our human emotions but also
because of hey i got your girlfriend or
hey
i you know i did this to you or hey i'm
disrespecting you and then you see this
all the time on worldstar hip hop people
reacting going up and and
having you know very dangerous you know
fights it elevates
the dynamics you talked about with the
pride the honor the ego that exactly
that whole thing
but also i mean you talked about the
situation of power i mean all the mass
shootings obviously i mean it's a it's a
cliche talking point but it always
happens in gun-free zones
it always happens in places where all of
a sudden you become the master of that
domain you're in charge you're calling
the shots
you're you're telling people where to do
what to say and you could just start you
know
you live like a god for a few minutes
and that's why they're drawn to these
places
to commit these heinous crimes because
it gives them power in their life that
they never had
seth rogen when he called that guy
stupid like if that guy seemed to handle
it i read
the thread and the guy kind of laughed
it off but if he had said that to the
wrong person and that person just stood
for
the weeks and months and years thinking
about seth rogen
and that guy went crazy and then went
and hunted seth rogen down that would
have been [ __ ]
they've been devastating for seth rogen
and and all the people that he knows
and that kind of stuff can happen if you
act like an ego idiot so
it's so i think it was i think it was
mike tyson who said a lot of people
online are acting like they never got
punched in the face
that's why bullying is good that's why
bullying is good if you if you bully and
you get bullied it creates this dynamic
or you're not going to mess with people
i i'm not saying you have to get rid of
it i'm not saying it's always great but
i'm saying there's a balance in society
it's part of growing up that's part of
development
fair conflict and struggle that's a
better word bullying is typically like a
disproportionate amount of power someone
you know
right i just think teaching people to
fight back i think you know in schools
they always teach you know you
go tell your teacher go report them
whatever i think if you get bullied you
get made fun of
push back do something it's gonna it's
better in the long term at least
i'm fascinated with videos of like
people fighting back against bullies and
just oh it's always great
remember that that video like years ago
that i think was in australia was like
that little that fat kid who was like
getting pushed around then he like
picked the guy up and he like threw him
down it was like everyone loved it
everyone loved it
it was a great power dynamic it shifted
he crushed the guy's back but like
he messed him up but that guy will never
that guy he probably did the best thing
to him because the guy that got thrown
on the floor
he's never going to go make fun of the
crazy neighbor because he knows
something bad could happen and instilled
in him a fear of messing with people and
now you mess with people less if we had
a personal combat expert on the show
right now they would be telling us
that's why jiu jitsu is great martial
arts are so important
to teach young people and people in
general there's i think i may have
referenced this at one point
on this show maybe months ago it's a
really funny video where a martial arts
instructor
promises to teach people the ultimate
move to always win
every fight they ever encounter and
everyone's all like oh we're gonna learn
from this master and he's like this one
technique
i can guarantee you will win every fight
so they all gather around they're all
sitting there and he stands there
and then he has his sparring partner
walk up to him and everyone's all ready
and then the master gets his fists ready
and then waves his arms in the air and
runs
full speed the other direction and
leaves the building and then everyone
starts laughing
and he comes back in and says any fight
you can escape is the fight you've won
the one technique to always win a fight
is not to fight and this is someone
who's teaching people how to fight
it's remarkable how the people who know
that why you don't have these conflicts
while you don't want to fight
are the ones who are typically pretty
good at it and when kids when you're
repeatedly bullied you're not able to
escape those are situations
where a kid has to see the same person
at school and in those situations
i mean honestly i think fighting back is
the right move
a lot for not speaking english and
looking weird and being
super pale and i had the whole bowl
haircut in brooklyn new york
and the way i got out of it is by
fighting you know but after
a year and a half of absolute misery and
torture and getting abused every day as
a little child
it has an effect on you but you know at
the end of the day i want to be
who i am if it wasn't for that uh
experience and and for me this is why i
always have a thing for the underdog i
always want the underdog to win
i always you know want to bet on the
underdog i always want to root for them
and i think that's because of my
experiences i was the same i moved we
moved around a lot i was always the new
kid i got bullied i remember one time
this kid was just would not stop
incessantly just on my case constantly i
remember punching him in the face
and it was the best feeling he never
bothered me again no one bothered me
again it changes
the dynamic and obviously if it happens
young when the stakes are low
it could avoid a situation like we just
talked about which was penis if that's a
big job we need to
teach people to stand up for themselves
in defense we don't want people to
aggress
you know exactly so if someone's
attacking you you defend yourself you
don't just
sit there and let they attack you you
don't want to break them you want to
subdue them ultimately yeah i i yeah and
i think the law is actually
perspective of the law it's like if you
have the ability to
to run or to flee or to detain them
instead of killing them you should
except in texas where there's just like
you could flee but you don't have to
well interestingly like you know in in
new jersey i believe
you have to flee your home if someone
breaks in and you can did you forget it
so a lot of what was instantly brought
up to me by other people is fleet of
wear
like if if you have nowhere to go what
do you do just flee into the woods in
the middle of winter and then freeze to
death
you need you need a home to live your
food your shelter but there are some
states that are like no you must run
away did you get into fights as a kid
uh i've only gotten a couple of fights
when i was a kid would you like how
would you get out of it
or how did you avoid fights in general
navigate it uh
i would just not escalate i would
typically be like i don't know man you
know i want to be involved
i was involved in too many and that's
probably why i slur my words now
you know being honest i got i got made i
wouldn't fight back and i just got
ostracized it was terrible i'd cry it
was horrible
i'd fight back and typically that would
stop it you would fight back
i only got into one fight and i got a
crap kick i got to fight i got into like
three fights
i still think that's better than not
fighting though in the chest and i hit
his g
he had a jean jacket on and i sliced my
finger on the button and i was like ow
and then you start punching me in the
face and i start crying
amazingly i only got into one fight that
was actually a sparring fight
where like the other kid was swinging
punches and then we just took a couple
punches each and then eventually the
fight just stopped
because it's like you get punched
several times i didn't start the fight
and then the other kid just stopped
swinging and then i was like all right
fight's over but then they're like
they're always grappling matches the
other person just tries to pin you and
they have no idea how to do it i will
tell you
taking it as long as they're without
fighting back i i have a seat of rage
in me it's it's really really intense
well the person who's the angriest
usually should win the fight i mean if
you're if i just feel like there's some
kind of power that comes with being so
mad and so pissed off that you don't
lose focus i think it equalizes a bit
i'm not saying it's going to flip
a lot of people don't know how to
breathe and they gas out all the time
once once you learn how to fight and you
learn how to breathe
there's a legit tactic in fighting to
get your opponent angry on purpose
so that they're not focused on strategy
and then you know i
i i briefly took a kung fu lesson
because i
actually lived above a kung fu dojo it
was really funny and so the guy like
whenever i'd walk by he'd be like just
hang out whenever you're coming down the
stairs
and the one thing explained to me is he
was like it's like it's like active
chess almost
you've got to know where they're going
to move when they're going to move and
what your move is going to be you need
to be thinking and strategizing the
whole time fast in real time
and if you get angry and you lose focus
and you go into a blind rage and start
swinging
that's when they figure out how to
easily trip you to grapple you to pin
you to misdirect you and you've lost
focus yeah the jab and the low kick are
the most powerful moves you can make now
in like mma combat
ian you should really start doing some
mma i have some pads maybe we could
start hitting some pads i just don't
want to hurt
people because i feel like but if you're
hitting pads i got some pads i got some
gloves
maybe we could you know i mean let's
let's jujitsu
let's arrange that and now move on to
super chats
i got into music that was how i get my
rage out i unloaded it
it's fun to punch you know screen all
right ladies and gentlemen
if you haven't already smash the like
button it really really does help
subscribe hit the notification bell
share the show with your friends if you
really do want to help that's like the
most powerful thing you can do but don't
forget
you can become the safety net for the
show by signing up at timcast.com to
become a member and get access
access to exclusive members only
segments they're like 20 minutes long
we got a couple hour long 45 minute long
hour long and we're gonna be doing more
and more and more we're gonna be
expanding the content we're gonna be
launching a vlog
there's a lot to come in the event we
eventually get banned like everybody
else
talking about very serious subjects well
timcast.com is where we will be
so um we may have a bonus i believe
we'll have a bonus segment up later
tonight we'll see how things
play out let's read some super chats we
have maxitrillion says hey tim who is
your favorite hero in one punch man
that's not even a fair question it's
obviously saitama what about you guys
who's your favorite hero one punch man
one punch man i don't know what you're
doing i don't know what that is the guy
that throws the punches
everyone out i'm kidding one punch man
is a very
i think it's like for a period it was
the most popular animation the ball dude
that throws the punches
right one punch man yeah saitama and uh
it was actually really popular among
non-anime fans united states
interestingly like everybody was into it
so what is it he just kills everyone
with one punch
uh when he chooses to do the irregular
punch his regular punch just ends
you know everyone and he's just it's
ultimate power it's kind of a satire on
these anime where like there's an
ultimate power guy
it's really funny logan brown says i'm
an army vet
left a few years ago a full stand down
for extremism just made my heart sink
crazy yeah we barely got into that i
wanted to say that
the whole um being against white
nationalism is is upsetting because the
military is national nationalist it's a
nationalist organization
and so what are they really against
they're trying to end white
well i think so they're trying to end
racism they're already going after white
nationals so if there's anyone in the
military that's openly like a neo-nazi
they're targeting them this is just
but they shouldn't be in the military if
you're a nationalist that's
good in the military that goes on
earlier the ideology that's greater than
the country i mean if it's a white
nationalist they're putting their race
above the country my issue with it is
we have civil rights in this country
what about a black nationalist
it's all bad same thing it's equally as
bad right so why are they focused on the
white
people yeah that's why i don't believe
they're being genuine and it looks like
a loyalty play
critical race theory is just as racist
as anything that's coming out of you
know
white supremacist movements the 1619
project all those are glorified by the
state they're all promoted by the state
because they're the preferred you know
supremacist ideology
uh you know of the day it's it's it's
their preferred version
they're going after versions of you know
supremacy and and
and and hateful ideas that they don't
like but it's just it's just
hypocritical
well let's yeah we'll we'll
insight of the ages says david pakman
lives in an alternate reality please
have him on for the lulls i honestly
think it's going to be critical for
public discourse
two movies on one screen would collide
we need this
i haven't uh been i used to watch more
of pac-man stuff i've been watching
lately so i don't i'm not entirely sure
what uh
you're referring to because you know i
haven't seen any of his latest stuff
uh so i don't know i i'd have no problem
with having david on i'm not sure he
would travel right now though
i think you know and i this is not meant
to be disparaging
people on the left don't travel right
now they're they're scared they're
worried about kovid
and so it's it's really difficult to
book them we tried having uh uh
vosh on with alex jones and he didn't
want to do it because of covet tried
having a bunch of other leftists on
either with or without alex jones before
we did the show we're trying to find a
guest to
sort of balance out and challenge jones
nobody would do it so eventually we got
michael malus
and michael's not certainly not a
leftist but he's a very intelligent
personality and i thought would work
really well
so we were like michael you have to come
you're you know it's gonna be awesome
so we did two episodes it was great rad
number two says the gadsden flag was
originally flown by the continental
marines
and the us navy jack flag from 01 to
2019
was a variation of the gadsden i don't
know how that can be seen as an
extremist symbol
because dc is occupied with barricades
in a green zone
and now they're coming and starting to
purge people from the military i mean
i don't know it seems like really
obvious that one ideology has finally
taken over and now they're excising all
those who oppose them
you know so yeah there you go welcome to
the you know new world
all right let's see america float says
conservative tim pool light equals
america floats just trying to keep the
country above water
love y'all except ian only like ian
oh jeez someone likes scandalous
s-head says so glad i'm not an active in
the marines anymore
but i can promise you that anyone openly
racist is quickly dealt with gets kicked
out we have a civil rights law you have
to
you have to serve this country and that
means people of all different
backgrounds and races and ideologies
it's been this way for decades so that i
understand
i just don't trust them louis
costa gliola says tim i suspect the
stand down isn't so much to weed out
anyone from the rank and file
but to purge the officer core of anyone
who would question the progressive party
line
that makes way more sense the enlisted
people just kind of
fall in line and do their thing you know
it's like what happened in the spanish
civil war was the junior officer
shooting the colonels and that's how
they basically you know took over the
military and wow
took over so i mean they got to make
sure the ranks all the way down are
completely
in line mfes says just ordered my i'm a
gorilla shirt and i've been reading
ishmael
tim have you thought of starting a book
club ian keep up the fermentation making
fun food is one of the most relaxing
ways to spend a sunday
uh get your exclusive i am a guerrilla
shirt you can see it's pinned above the
chat or you can go to timcast.com click
that shop button
and we have the we have the i am a girl
shirt we also have the haram shirt
and we're working on a couple more
shirts we'll have more coming if you
could pick a book for everyone to read
what would you pick oh man i i've read a
lot of books in my day
i've read harry potter and the
philosopher's stone i'm sorry sorceress
done for you
americans i've read harry potter and the
chamber of secrets oh one book i love
was harry potter and the prisoner
i'm kidding it's all anybody ever reads
in fact um
what what i would say is read the
original secret window from stephen king
if you've seen the movie uh the story
was good
the the movie wasn't as good um what was
still life with woodpecker i read a
really really long time ago i enjoyed i
can't remember who wrote that the
the author but uh i'm not a big book
reader but i will say
watch the movie secret window of johnny
depp then read the story and you're
gonna go
because the story is actually good i'm
not gonna spoil it though what books
would you guys
shout out if you had one fiction not
fiction doesn't matter it doesn't matter
uh what was the uh the stranger camus
oh what about yourself uh jurassic park
uh what was the book um the the
what about the seven daily habits seven
daily traits i forgot the name of it oh
what the heck
no that's how to win for uh when when
franklin yeah win friends and
great books what about you lydia me
i really like stoicism so i'd probably
recommend uh marcus aurelius's uh
meditations big time the philosopher
king
oh yeah here's a book you definitely
gotta read uh it is called
trust me i'm lying by ryan holiday
confessions of a media manipulator
oh i think that's what his confessions
of media manipulator ryan holliday is a
brilliant dude who who wrote about how
he tricked journalists into putting fake
quotes from fake experts
how to use marketing schemes and stuff
he's a he's a smart guy
so yeah trust me i'm lying all right
let's see john mitch says it's going to
be real awkward when they realize that
we all wear the gadsden flag on our
working uniform in the navy
uh-huh yeah it will be thinking like
that there were national guardsmen
apparently he posted some gads and
flying
like get him out rocky range says what
scares me the most
is that the left does not seem to be
aware of what they are becoming what
angers me the most is my good friend who
grew up in the 1930s germany has to live
through a second
time yeah during occupy wall street
there was this like
older uh uh he was it was a cop who was
like slightly older middle age like an
old guy
and i saw this uh leaning up on on the
on on the barricades talking to some of
these young
occupy lefties and i was like that's
really interesting cops normally don't
talk to people
this guy was born in the soviet union
and his parents brought him to the u.s
when he was younger and so he grew up in
the soviet union
and he was like you guys i lived through
this
i see what you're doing it's the exact
same thing
this is what leads to you know
eventually this you know
the communist soviet takeover the
authoritarianism and
this was after we saw the first initial
wave of occupying it became the critical
race theory
weird culti takeover it's what my family
keeps warning me about
every day that i talk to them what are
they saying they're like uh
communism happened under our lifetime
and it's gonna happen again probably
soon
here uh probably in the western world
yeah yeah
dano says this is for luke to buy some
plant allies now that he can take a plot
of land in the chas garden for colored
and indigenous people oh thank you how
much was the super chat it was ten
dollars i'm gonna remember that one i'm
writing that down
john society says i guess you can
eliminate half of the usmc
for doing official u.s business in
africa asia and the middle east
there you go josh jack says stalin
purged his military in 1941
for the exact same reasons the dod is
purging it now
be ready and don't forget i'll just
leave it there
quagan says the far left is racist
against asians yes
they support policies that discriminate
against asian such as affirmative action
in universities
yes they do they even hate they even
hate the vietnamese they
they call themselves ahahaha it's a
funny joke
they call themselves antifa you know you
guys don't fuzz
right that's delicious i i don't like it
really yeah i don't like food have some
cookies ever have shabu
no no it's where you it's where they
give you a boiling pot and they give you
all the raw vegetables and meat
and then you boil it in front of you
yeah we did that in korea yeah
no no no we did korean bbq which is also
really fun where they put the food in
the thing korean barbecue is amazing
if you're in uh new york city go down to
orchard street in manhattan and check
out anne choi
maybe it's on choi i was like best fun
we were in korea and i was like i'm
gonna be very critical of this korean
barbecue because my mom's half korean so
i've had some good korean food
and the full korean people are like what
they had they had puppy
um puppy cafes we went to the dog cat
fan like a dog like just like and we did
a live stream that was demonetized
and i'm like what no no no it was the
raccoon cafe oh
okay so look at this lou we literally
went to south korea i can't remember
where
why did we go there uh i forgot there
was oh it was something about missiles
in north korea or whatever i don't know
there's so
there's i think there's a conference or
something now i don't remember but we
were in korea
it was some it was some global like war
issue that we went down there and talked
to people
but we decided to spend one day and i
was like i'm just gonna make a video
about this raccoon cafe it was totally
apolitical they demonetized it i
i was like let's see how ridiculously
safe
and pc we could get and let's do a live
stream
in a puppy cafe and a raccoon one we
went to both
but but we live streamed i think at the
puppy one and
i think though the the video is still up
on my channel and that was demonetized
and i'm like this is ridiculous
it's a video of work at a raccoon cafe
and it's titled puppies
yeah puppy cafe raccoon cafe is where
you go and there's raccoons everywhere
just doing raccoon stuff
and you like watch them as they eat and
they like hobble around they're like
jump
on you yeah i got demonetized then i was
like i don't i don't get it man yeah
they were funny they're rolling around
and they're you know wiggling and i'm
like it's like
we thought doing the familiest
friendliest thing possible they'd be
like okay you're good they're like nah
so demonetized yeah all right marcus
carter says
our politicians create our division
simply to retain power america was
designed by the people for the people
americans and mass must reclaim
representation and run for office
great show guys appreciate it petty says
i'd like to point out
madison's original draft of the bill of
rights with special attention to the
first and fifth articles
i'm a staunch anti-federalist but i
sincerely believe the original first
amendment is the only way forward for
the union
yeah which one was that one well madison
had a a different version of the bill of
rights that it wasn't like an it was 17
articles yeah and it was incorporated
and there was a pre-preamble and
they they talked it had uh rights of
conscience i believe was already
included
the first amendment which was never uh
ratified like i think the third
amendment
the third article was free speech the
first one had something to do
with what congress well there was
there's the there's the madison
uh proposal and then there was the first
amendment which we were talking about
which was the congressional
apportionment which was like 40 000 per
percent or something yeah it would have
made like a crazy
crazy sized house but i think i don't
know if this this individual is
referencing there was a madison proposal
which had even more amendments that had
a bigger bill of rights that was really
interesting
oh well zone nation says on the daughter
of
army world-class sniper they need to
walk this back now
they can have my guns all right i'll
stop there
basically said molon labe i'll put it
that way
spaceko says china couldn't have jordan
peterson teaching us to make our beds
first and cleaning our rooms
i mean look look how they went after
jordan peterson they attacked him even
recently yeah
yeah yeah in an inspirational way it was
like it was so unfair
you should take care of yourself and and
be responsible and find the heaviest
thing you can carry and carry it
and then they're like how dare you you
nazi
self-improvement is white nationalism
you're gonna have uh brett weinstein on
the show
soon so i would advise checking oh yeah
we invited him but i think travel's an
issue
you know i mean they're on the other
side of the country you know what i mean
maybe yeah didn't they just go to la for
bill maher though
i mean they're always welcome brett's
right right yeah he was in l.a
all right let's see here mike jesus i
have a biochem degree one of the issues
we studied could be uh that could be
leading to low t
is the massive excess estrogen and
prostate and prostagin
via birth control women peeing out of
their system it does not break down
yeah so if you're on what city water
you're basically drinking a bunch of
birth control that's all i drink is i
drink straight from the tap
yeah yeah i've been saying don't drink
the tap water it's not like happening in
your ears now i thought the tap in new
york was supposed to be one of the
better ones but i guess well in terms of
that's what the government wants you to
think
in terms of contaminants and like
illnesses yeah but there's still
other stuff of course yeah the realist
sociology says
sociologist says t levels are down 50
since the 40s
and down 1 per year since the 1980s
this is an ignored epidemic tea is a
wellness hormone
not necessarily a masculinity hormone
but i think they do want to feminize us
agreed tk 1960 says tim recommend you
read the empire core by christopher g
nuttle the the chapter lead-ins are
hauntingly accurate for the current
condition of our country
very interesting regarding the super
chat before you think that they're this
global
establishment that's doing like the
great reset and all that wants people
let like more docile less aggressive so
they want less testosterone in the
systems yeah
i don't think it's crazy to say that
there are people in power who study how
to maintain their power and expand it
and they look throughout history and
they said you know what we need to
feminize society we need to make people
docile and they're easier to control
it could be accidental it could be
deliberate it doesn't matter we we
shouldn't fight we shouldn't theorize it
i think but we should understand it
feminize is absolutely the incorrect way
to describe this
absolutely yeah you're right you're
right it's more like infantilized yeah
you're right
they want they so you know i was reading
i read this interesting thing about
dog domestication they talked about how
proto dogs
the first dogs were essentially a great
word phrase by the way what proto dog
proto dogs that's
that's the word so there were wolves and
then there was a new breed of proto-dog
they were still wolves but they were
adapted and grew up with humans
and were more accommodating eventually
though we selected
we selected the dogs that were less
likely the wolves that were less likely
to fight us and attack us
essentially creating a permanent child
so
dogs as i was reading are very much like
they never grew up
so you have people who are essentially
now scared of words
unable to support themselves and they're
very much becoming very
infantilized we're being bred into that
yeah i don't i don't know if bread is
the right word like social conditioning
like i said we're shut down so we can't
go interact with each other
but we can go online and be told these
opinions that we're allowed to believe
while everything else is removed
only acceptable opinions are allowed in
the machine and no one will have to go
and talk to each other
debt collector says i'm vegan and i
don't take and i don't take vitamins and
i'm 100 healthy
and in 220 uh 2020 i felt amazing
how long have you been vegan no they
can't respond okay
gracefang says keto carnivore problem
solved that's true man
you know what really really bugs me is
people don't know what keto is and
genesis yep people people are like oh
i'm doing keto and i'm like i
couldn't help but notice that you're
eating a large steak and chicken like
it's keto i'm like
no it isn't like i think it's called
gluconeogenesis
you eat a bunch of protein it just turns
into sugar keto is like drinking a glass
of heavy whipping cream for breakfast
yeah and then eating an avocado with
cheese for lunch and yes some protein
and less carbs
but people like they say they're doing
keto and they're doing atkins
it's like oh i'm doing keto and i'm like
keto is awesome
your body starts swelling because it's
digesting the fat
swelling yeah you'll feel your body like
swelling as it's doing it
well i read this crazy thing about like
mental
cognition improved 25 and muscle
endurance improves 25
because all of a sudden your body's got
instant access to all this energy
using ketones instead of you know uh uh
glucose sugar but uh my understanding is
that
that high fat diet like ridiculously
high fat makes testosterone go crazy
and then dudes are just like i'm gonna
fight you i drink heavy whipping cream
and they go nuts alan ortega says meat
is very important to human diet
i went full carnivore my anxiety went
away and i'm healthier than ever before
with no supplements
the main problem is seed oils and
monocropping
sugar is bad for all yes you know when
it comes to eating meat i wonder about
salt because a lot of meats are salted
so like you gotta be you gotta be
careful about your salt intake too i
feel like meats were even more salted in
the past when they didn't have you know
refrigerators and all that and they were
not as bad as we're facing today so
i don't know if it can be that bad yeah
let's see
alina bushong says on low t a
fascinating behavior study in rats in a
utopian setting called universe 25.
interesting zen dong stuff says great
show
testosterone testosterone i know
evolutionary biologist b
weinstein heather hein have talked about
this extensively on their dark horse
podcast
a lot of good data from their research
as i recall i'll have to reach out and
see if they would like to come on the
show
i i know they might not want to travel
you know when they went on uh
bill maher they were socially distanced
daniel laster says i just got diagnosed
today with low t and my condition
started after working in corrections
it could be escalating destabilization
in america
daniel maxwell says how long have u.s
farmers been using genetically modified
seeds to grow crops
that could have a major impact on the
nutrient value in the food crops
one of those unintended consequences of
genetic modification
gavin young says how about the wide
availability of
adult content if you don't have a
physical need to go out and find a mate
your body has no need to supply the
energy to maintain the structures that
attract a potential mate but
testosterone is more than that
it's not just about the masculinity
thing it's literally about like making
your body function
like i think bone density too i'm
shocked we didn't bring up porn though i
mean porn is so destructive mentally i
mean it's like
i think equivalent to just using cocaine
regularly almost or something like that
i forgot the uh
the drug uh equivalence well it has very
damaging effects for
young people right there's also some
people thinks it boosts up your tea
so it's so kind of like a conflict lose
it or use it
kind of like that four and six year olds
are seeing that stuff
and now 10 years later and 15 years
later those are the people that are out
there all twisted
maybe it's something about seeing like
just because there's like most porn is
like
violent it's like people like ah what's
like porn escalation you need like a new
you need to like
up it even more but there are kicks
there's like video of people having
loving
sex that you can watch and you call that
porn but i think a lot of people think
that that's what
sex is people want to see like like a
he-man kind of dude like
holding a woman who's in like airplane
and he throws her and then she does a
triple backflip and then falls off a
cliff with a parachute
and then she lands in a pool full of
like you know men and women
like they want the craziest most extreme
like that's the escalation right yeah
it's like using drugs you need a you
know
like yeah you have to get a better high
and it's like you know that's what it is
wow someone's watching the love scene i
don't think i do this
we got an interesting one jeffrey grunt
says i remember the end of a captain
planet episode
where captain said try keep your family
to one
kid fry try to keep your family to
two it's it's it's poorly phrased but i
think he's saying to keep your family to
one kid
what do you guys remember that no i
don't remember bd blake says if you live
in pennsylvania the governor taxes
people with few kids to pay for school
taxes and people with more kids to be
exempt
incentive for kids wasn't uh what
country was it
childless tax no they were like we're
going to give you money if you hunger
hungry hungry in poland poland giving
money to people
uh if you have you know more than one
child child
i think in the soviet union too they
also had a they would tax you if you
were childless
so they was like it was uh incentive and
also just punishment
olay uh let's see olay cab
says i've been depressed nearly all my
life i started taking vitamin d
supplements
and uh for a month i started taking
vitamin supplements and vitamin d for a
month and
or two and within two weeks i felt free
from the chains of depression
yeah a lot of people are vitamin d
deficient uh check your levels
get some sun the new ikb says if you
have made enough enemies that is not
possible for you to fly in a commercial
flight
then you done messed up no one is more
hated than a hypocrite
interesting
john branson says matter generates and
is made of energy
it's only natural that the world will
find a way to return matter to energy
regardless of its state
and return that energy into matter
natural life is a cycle
ah let's see four cdn name change says i
get a kick out of how we repurpose this
collected plastic to make crappy
bracelets
which you can buy so you feel like
you're doing something to help the
planet which people end up throwing out
and back into the ocean and they go
yeah that's a good point i bought
says all politicians should have two
livestr should have to live stream their
entire life while in office
the corrupt will bail out and the cost
will be easily covered after the
corruption is
uprooted that way we'll have people in
office who only serve the people
stop the manipulation and have
transparency 24 7 surveillance even when
they're in the party
all phone calls on public issues are
publicly available that was almost like
the kardashians though and look with
them like they had cameras on them all
the time and they loved it i mean
transparency let's do it ethan johansen
says next time you speculate on gmos and
farming practices on here
please have an actual farmer on to tell
our side of the story and why we do what
we do
like mn millennial farmer zach johnson
brian's brown farming videos or how
farms work ryan k
interesting a farmer would be nice to
change things up on here
i think i would like that we've been
really we've been really trying to get
researchers from universities on
near-death experiences and life after
death but
it's just it's hard to get non-pop
cycle like if someone's doing research
on something very trendy or popular
then it's very easy to get them and book
them if it's political it's very easy
more scientists in general more people
like dr chris martinson
yeah that was great great that was great
so yeah well we're trying the problem is
people in politics are they want to have
their message out there
so you know you'll get these people who
are just like absolutely desperate to
get their message like like the
president of
the new york young republicans club will
be like i want to i'm just kidding
but if you don't know any good
scientists reach out to us i think you
have an email you can reach out to me
even it doesn't matter
we have a we have a new general inquiry
email it's info at timecast.com i sent
you some info is jeremy risk he's uh the
alien scientist on youtube and he wants
to talk about the
the senate disclosure that got slipped
into the code yeah yeah
he's been oh the ufos yeah that's coming
in june i think we have
i think guys we have a crazy bonus
segment for the
no it's more than that it's the navy
claiming to have reality engineering
technology
like dude what if everything we've been
seeing over the past four years have
been them screwing with
reality philadelphia like in the matrix
no no no but they're saying they have
tech that like engineers reality to some
degree
what probably remember that that big
conspiracy theory the philadelphia
experiment with the boat
and that was like a movie or a book that
wasn't real at all well i mean
this sounds i mean this but there's that
was real the philadelphia experiment yes
it was
uh i don't think you're correct okay it
wasn't based on a movie i mean it was a
conspiracy but then what is it
there was some i mean i don't even know
where to begin with it i think it was a
navy
experiment that they were running it
wasn't a book or movie
yeah exactly it wasn't it was an
experiment and like something happened
with the boat and like
it was weird they thought it was nothing
people were like it's not so the origin
of the story is a
is a is a book called the case for the
ufo about ufos and the exotic means of
propulsion they might use
and then he said he received two letters
from carlos miguel allende
carl m allen who claimed to have
witnessed a secret world war ii
experiment called the philip
at the philadelphia naval shipyard in
the experiment he claimed the destroyer
the uss eldridge was rendered invisible
so i'm pretty sure it didn't happen
well you know the us government always
does really wacky crazy stuff
including you know the story about the
men who stare at goats
and i actually talked to some of those
scientists involved and they were
talking about high-level quantum physics
and
manifestation and spirituality there was
also a movie based on that but one of
the
high level kind of generals involved in
that actually reached out to me i
actually spent time with him in chile
and he blew my mind away we are going to
have a bonus segment talking about all
this stuff because this is crazy
they claim to engineer reality so we'll
get to it let's see where we're at
we got some super chats we got some more
super chats jandyn patterson
says timmy become a i can't see what
that emoji is
uh a bird a what is it oh it says it's
an eagle
uh gorilla or an orangutan
not a sheep sheep sheep it's time to
play in the grass with all of these
snakes
and see how far we make it play the game
but smarter good luck everyone and stay
sane exiles later cast appreciate the
support thank you
ian k says tim love your show you and
your team are a light in the darkness
please talk about the great reset we we
definitely did get into that quite a bit
today i do all the time
i mean how can you not i'm just
eternally grateful to finally
you know all of these evil
planet-destroying
children having white supremacists are
now going to get stopped by the great
wonderful schwab cabal clown schwab
that guy strait of a bond movie like he
just looks evil he doesn't even try to
hide it
it's just like he's central casting for
evil and he doesn't even care
all right we got we got too many super
chats you guys this is just too many
super chits we really appreciate it we
want more thank you so much but i can't
read them all
reoccupy wall street says we are in awe
of the elite response towards the
gamestop rebellion
in our response we made reoccupy wall
street dot co
in it we have some funny
anti-establishment memes and merch check
site for more
that's the funny thing the main reason
we we hit up gavin is because you were
setting up reoccupy wall street and i
was like
you know you mentioned there are a lot
of leftists coming at you i'm like they
finally convinced
some republicans to be like you know
maybe we should occupy wall street and
they're like no
not you get out of here yeah like what
what this is great we barely got into it
where you got were you are you like what
how do you feel about the federal
reserve oh i hate the federal reserve i
mean
now you guys are friends you're just
friends i i was like
i'm a rob i was a ron paul guy i mean i
was like you know i've read rothbard all
that kind of stuff so i'm all in with
with
the the creature from jekyll island all
that but you know what happened i mean
that's that was
more 2008 2010 with with the fed
creating these these
male incentives and all this this
horrible and you know
excess credit on the markets but now
it's just these it's kind of an elitist
type of thing because it's like rules
for
for thee but not for me you know we can
we can overshore we could do all this
ridiculous
market manipulation but the second
little guy has the tools to do it
you know shut it down and we went there
and we were saying that and the leftists
agree with us some of them would have
just like to shut down the markets
completely
you know my view was this was a
self-regulating aspect the over short
balanced out the over short
uh so the short squeeze balanced out the
over short excuse me
all right we got this one from emmanuel
and g says i love you tim ian lids and
luke gavin it's too soon for me to get
attached
low ppm drug water filtration technology
exists but you won't get that mass
produced without someone making money
money money that would be great
filtering water better won't give you
votes either that is how what we use
graphing for is water filtration
dretv says you will see a return of
plato's philosopher kings
they arise in an empire's time of crisis
like like donald trump the true
philosopher
i'm kidding no but maybe
maybe in 2024 we'll actually get a i
hope so man
well i don't know maybe carlson
i wouldn't actually want a philosopher
king but a philosopher president
for four years maybe eight would be uh
would be pretty good i'm the secretary
of state
i'm into it mishkola says
i'm an uh agronomist the decline in
nutrition in our crops coincides with
the increase in fertilizer use
interesting wow matt penn says gavin
looks like a young richard kind
okay all right trucker hat says also
check out marine corps
looks at building three new pacific
regiments to counter china
marine counter china marine corps times
interesting
clyde b6 as may i suggest tom clancy's
rainbow six it's an older book but fun
to read
oh wow i did play the video game it was
really good
catherine lowe says tim the last refuge
tweeted your last aoc segment about 40
minutes ago
the truth will come out p.s luke's got a
sweater in 1984 but we are
but we are change came off what's the
last refuge
is that a podcast i don't know yeah look
at it
i think it's a podcast huh gigachad says
men get your testosterone levels checked
do your research and get treated if you
need it
trt is a life changer well that's why
i've been telling everyone get your
blood levels tested
we just take the alex jones supplements
and be fine oh yeah it's just one right
here
jane markham says try to get colleen
noir on to talk about 2a would be a
great fun convo
yeah we i've talked to coleen we've
definitely wanted him to have him on the
show he seemed he seems awesome
it was colin this whole time it's colean
yeah
i don't know he'll correct us when he
comes in the show okay when he when he
inevitably comes in the show in the next
week or two
ds says hi tim i had a cool out-of-body
death experience when i was stabbed in
baltimore in a robbery attempt
i died for 45 minutes i left my body
whoa
tell us more crazy
all right let's just read a couple more
here barry kitchen says our bodies are
resilient things we adapt situations
times are soft so we don't need high
testosterone low t equals depression
and prostate yeah yeah that apoptosis
phenomena where certain cells when
they're unneeded will just destroy
themselves in the body that's like i
feel like society's
getting rid of the t-cells yeah that's
crazy all right vasht says the philly
experiment
the ship was said to have disappeared
but it just stopped showing up on radar
very interesting my friends if you
haven't already smash the like button
and go to timcast.com become a member
because we're gonna do a crazy
weird ufo technology segment for members
only coming up soon
you can follow me on instagram twitter
and minds
for the time being i'll always be on
mines though they're not going to ban me
because they're legit
at timcast and you can check out my
other youtube channels
youtube.comtimcast
youtube.comcastnews we do this show
monday through friday live at 8 pm we'll
be back tomorrow of course
if you're listening on the podcast leave
a good review otherwise subscribe like
button notification bell and share this
share the show with your friends and uh
gavin you have anything you want to
mention
uh no social media thank you guys for
having me on follow me at gavin wax
and i'm looking forward to doing more
with you guys appreciate it man thanks
for coming
thank you and if you want to support me
and my independent efforts you can by
just simply purchasing a t-shirt and
then virtue signaling to everyone around
you
by going to thebestpoliticalshirts.com
and i also run an independent media
channel called we are change on the
youtube channel we are change that is
really ridiculous and really fascist
that you could still somehow watch and
it's still on youtube
good stuff and i'm ian crossland you can
follow me also onlines and i know it's
awesome because i helped create it
uh youtube twitter facebook instagram at
ian crossland you can also follow me on
twitch
and follow my daily streams though i
didn't do any yesterday day before gavin
this was really awesome
thanks for coming out thanks for coming
i want to go deeper on the federal
reserve one day oh let's do it
i love it and i am sour patch lids you
can follow me on twitter at sour patch
lids i'm also
on mines at sour patch lids and i am on
gab and instagram at real sour patchlets
the us navy has patents on tech it says
we'll engineer the fabric of re
fabric the fabric the fabric of reality
i did rudowski it will engineer the
fabric of reality if you want to hear
more about it go to timcast.com become a
member and we will see you all there
you